Hey fuckers,
this episode of the Joe Rogan experience is brought to you by Tang dog and
trust.
Did you know that 98% of people would save money with Ting?
Now,
why?
It's because they do mobile different ways.
I mean it sounds so insurance have to write things like that.
If you have a company you have to actually like have like sentences that people
can repeat.
But this is what I can tell you about Tang.
What's good about Tang is that ting is a website,
a um,
a company rather that provides you with cell phone service without a lot of the
bullshit that's usually attached to cell phone service.
Like for instance,
hidden costs,
early termination fees,
cancellation fees,
which are actually really,
you're buying the phone.
It's,
it's cancellation fees are really weird because it's um,
what they're doing.
Like if you buy a phone and across you 200 bucks,
it doesn't really cost you 200 bucks.
Probably Cross,
you're like six,
but he'd take four of that hundred and they sort of defer it over a few years.
Now if you want to get out of your contract,
they say,
no,
no.
You've got to give us money buddy.
You'll owe less money.
So this phone that you thought you were buying for 200 bucks,
it's really 500 bucks.
Tingles isn't bullshit you,
they sell you the best android phones you could possibly buy all the newest,
coolest android phones and,
and there are a ton of them.
There's a Samsung Galaxy note three,
which is the one that I use,
which is just excellent,
is this big giant ass screen.
And he used to be one time that if you didn't have an iPhone,
you were fucked.
It used to be that,
you know,
I phones were just through technology.
It was so much more advanced in the android phones.
I had an early android phone and it was like a,
like a drunk.
It was just like a dumb drunk that you were trying to get to work for you.
You come on stupid like pressed a button over and over again.
Oh you fuck head.
And I come from an iPhone,
which is just glorious.
It was just amazing.
But now there's,
there's no difference in using them and you most certainly can save money with
Ting.
Go to rogan.ting.com and save 25 bucks off of a,
uh,
for one of your first devices.
Um,
and like I said,
we know several people that use it.
Chris Ryan,
he uses it.
He uses Tang cause of this podcast.
That's how influential this ting Ghana try believe it bro.
I'm jump convincing PhDs,
Yo and Chris,
Ryan and Dunkin.
I will do a round,
what is it,
five or something like that?
Four or five.
Four or five real soon.
We're going to be doing that on April 8th.
Is that what it is?
I think it is.
I think it's April eight.
April 8th.
Yeah.
You need your volume turned down there and just say it.
Sorry,
I don't want to interrupt.
You don't have to worry about it man.
We'll call how many times you've been here.
It doesn't matter.
I'm scared
to move in.
Go to [inaudible] dot com check.
Save yourself some money.
Some money guys come on and an excellent cell phone company.
And by the way,
they use the sprint backbone.
That's an important point.
It's not like some wonky ass system.
They use sprint,
you pay
for sprint,
the sprint service,
but you get it and under like,
you know,
tings,
ideas,
the weighting wants to run things which are very cool.
They also recently cut their rates,
cut the rates just to celebrate their second anniversary and they uh,
they,
they addressed them even further to uh,
for heavy users like looking at lower cost because some you freaks out there,
can't stop looking at Shit online and you get ridiculous cell phone bills with a
lot of companies if you go like way over here.
Oh your limit.
I've been hammered by them.
Do you ever hear about that guy in Canada who,
I don't know.
He was an idiot and he watched porn on his phone and Canada didn't have the
right thing set up.
I guess he watched porn for a few days,
left it on.
He got a cell phone bill for like $80,000,
like some insane cell phone bill where he had to go to court cause he's like,
there's no way this could have caused you that much.
But then yeah you left his phone on or I don't remember how it happened but wow,
that shit can happen man.
It's almost like an old joke that people say that they would uh,
call China from your house and leave the phone off the hook.
I remember like,
cause long distance was so expensive we had to call somewhere.
It was so expensive from places cost different amounts.
Like you could call three counties away and it'd be like a nickel more for some
unknown reason.
Like the power lines were more dangerous there,
whatever,
whatever it took for your voice to get there.
It was a little more expensive.
They had us,
what it was was they had us,
no way you could get any kind of service and then cell phones came along and
then slowly but surely people started using cell phones as their main phone.
And then the other thing happened,
his cell phone stopped charging for roaming.
You kind of use your phone anywhere now they just let it go.
So it was just like this mad competition scramble and that's opened the door for
companies like ting cause with Tim has done it.
They rent time on the sprint backbone.
So you get sprint type service but you get an under tanks rules.
That sounds so weird.
Why does it sound weird?
Renton time on a backbone.
I don't understand what a backbone is.
It's all just noise.
A D it sounds like a demon runs team.
His name is teeing or at the very least some chance.
That spirit.
It's a controlling the called the sprint spine.
Yeah.
I live on the spine of sprints.
Like I'm picturing like a whispery ghosts,
like character.
It doesn't have like a real form,
but you know it's there.
We could never put it in the glass though.
Couldn't like hold it down.
It's not like a genie.
You mean some vapers spirit just to science to cling to the spine.
For some reason you got a demon on your spam boy Mris and they see this fucking
thing moving around,
hiding from the cameras and shit.
Oh,
it's like a kind of holding its ears because it doesn't like the sound,
the Mri.
I don't,
don't tell him.
Tell him man.
I don't know.
Do you believe in demons?
No.
Anyway,
Rogan gutting Dotcom,
you believe in phone spines were also brought to you by on it on it.
Makers have a one 80,
which is what we're drinking right now,
son.
Uh,
what one is,
is,
uh,
it's my favorite shit to take when I fly because flying is a motherfucker on
your immune system and your brain for some weird reason.
And what we came up with for people that are just a little bit jet lagged a
little bit,
um,
a little bit whacked out of system.
Um,
the idea is to give you the neurotransmitter support of Alpha brain and the best
adaptogens from shroom tech sport,
little five HTP from new mood and some minerals for the immune system and all
these,
you know,
these nutrients in water scares you a little boost.
It gives your brain what you need,
especially when you're coming from me.
It's a big one.
I take two of these actually.
I'm mixed them together.
When I,
uh,
when I fly anywhere,
it's just when I land I always feel like shit.
And this is the only thing that I've ever found that gets me out of it.
This and exercise exercise is another one that gets you out of it.
And when I say feel like shit,
like not really bad,
but I don't feel awesome and that's what we're trying to do with the things that
we sell it on it.
Everything we're trying to do,
we're trying to sell things that we find that a beneficial,
whether it's beneficial for cognitive function and whether it's beneficial for
your recovery,
from training for strength and conditioning equipment.
Ecstasy,
dude,
that's what we used to sell back in the day.
That was one of the first ideas.
It was called roll on.
Roll off.
Yeah.
It was one,
one set of pills was to enhance the ecstasy experience.
But Pri providing you with a additional neurotransmitter's
poor man,
I,
I can't do it anymore.
I take ecstasy,
ecstasy now,
and it's just like I get depressed for a week.
When I was a kid,
I used to gobble it,
I could gobble it and the next day everything's fine,
but now it's just maybe the ecstasy has gotten worse.
Well,
it's also,
is it pure?
Because Brian says that if it's pure,
you don't ever feel it.
Like he says that like the next day you're fine.
I get the feeling with pure ecstasy is the same thing with gluten free bread.
Somebody figured out.
Yeah,
just say it's pure charged him more dollars because no one is testing gluten
bread.
No one's like,
oh,
is this truly gluten free?
But they aren't testing ecstasy.
Like that's one thing that people do at some raves,
so it'd be a classic ecstasy for gluten free bread is better than regular bread.
Better.
I mean you feel you feel better.
It's a better trip.
Yes.
It's definitely a better trip,
but it's not enough for me to eat.
It just grows.
It just tastes like shit of never funny.
Gluten free bread,
not,
I've had some good gluten free stuff though.
I've had good gluten free stuff.
I've had some really good gluten free cookies.
I've had some really good gluten free pasta,
like fresh pasta.
There's a company that makes it,
I don't remember the name,
but they make it and like those,
those plastic covered little tubs where it's like they're fresh noodles.
They're not like they're not hard plastic that you boil like you boil them for a
very short amount of time,
but they taste a lot like regular noodles.
It tastes like normal spaghetti.
I had these gluten free pancakes at Millie's on sunset boulevard and silver
lake.
There's,
they taste exactly like pancakes and that made me think,
oh these are just regular pancakes are just suspicious.
There's so good.
I'm suspicious because usually gluten tastes like stale,
like when you're desperate for all free.
Does gluten free tastes like it's stale usually are like,
it's not that good,
but yeah,
I don't know man.
I don't know about gluten free or organic.
I mean I know it's better when it is gluten free or organic,
but how often is that really gluten free?
Well with gluten free,
it's pretty obvious because what,
what are the ingredients?
Why would they lie about it?
Because he charged you be getting sick if it wasn't.
Yeah,
you can't do that because some people have like legit,
I don't have a legit gluten allergy,
but some people do,
they have crones disease.
Those people get really sick if you start eating gluten right.
And they have like real bowel issues too apparently from that stuff,
just their body just doesn't,
their intestines stretch out.
Their intestines are apparently like,
it's like someone took your intestines and like pulled them too far out and they
just,
they're like wire he and stretched.
Imagine if you are a doctor and you know,
to explain to someone what was wrong with him.
He met with that like show off like,
God,
I'm fucking diagnosis.
Is that,
can you like can stretch them?
Jesus,
man,
tell me some good news.
Help me out here,
doc.
You're freaking me the fuck out.
You got to like spaghetti friend.
Um,
there's a big 48 hours here.
Gold sale going on right now.
Um,
uh,
at on it,
one day in 19 hours and 22 minutes left as of this,
uh,
this broadcast go to on a top comm,
o n n I t used the Codeword Rogan save 10% off any and all supplements.
Boom.
That's it.
Cues,
music,
Duncan trussell's here.
Doug pounds here or
experience
good
trustless and idea the night we worked at the comedy Magic Club.
We had a great time,
very fun.
And then um,
I drove dunk it back to his house and we sat around and we uh,
we watched a bunch of TV together,
which is something I'd never get to do,
man.
Well not even TV.
We watched the Internet and I got to watch uh,
some,
a dog stuff.
I got to watch God Doug Pound Pound House.
Really,
really fucking funny stuff.
We were laughing really hard.
How many of we watch at least four or five,
right?
Blanche man,
we went through a bunch.
It's so good because you just want to eat it because it's got like a through
line happening and you just want to keep seeing what happens next.
So weird.
I don't give them chances to like,
hang on,
what if I'm not on the road?
Yeah.
We don't have obligations enough to be somewhere so after the show.
That was so fun.
So fun to do.
Yeah,
man,
that was a blast.
Yeah.
It's so weird how easy it is in Los Angeles.
Did just get sort of like reclusive and separated or that stuff doesn't happen
that much and it's,
it was a blast but doesn't have as much as well.
Just how everyone is so self involved.
We're all so busy and we're adults.
Yeah.
I mean,
let's face it,
it's not like we're 16 year olds.
We can't,
like you don't get a chance to get reclusive.
What do you mean?
Is that what you were saying?
No,
no,
no.
He's saying you get recruited,
you don't get a chance to hang.
You don't get a chance to hang.
Okay.
Right.
Because people get so sucked into their business and their jobs and their
families.
Yeah.
You put,
it really becomes,
there's that,
that old cliche that really does hold true.
It's like w what?
What's more valuable to you?
Money or happiness because sometimes you do have to make that sort of
distinction.
Yeah.
Like you have to say,
look,
I,
I could use some more money,
but you know what?
I will have a great fucking time if I hang out with my friends right now.
How much,
how much should I spend trying to collect money?
How much should I spend hanging out with my friends?
Because it seems like the friends part makes me happier.
So like how do you figure that out?
And along the line,
I think a lot of us get obligations and mortgages and what have you.
That starts leaning you towards the money side instead of towards the fun side.
And that's like really what turns people in.
The old men.
Yes.
That's how you get home.
Hunched,
hunched down and sick.
Yeah.
I like to,
uh,
say no to jobs.
Um,
I,
my main Gig is like editing and,
uh,
it's hard to say no to a job when they're offering you money in it.
Right.
But you work a lot.
I've been working too much the last few years,
but now I came to this realization that I gotta start saying no to jobs.
Now I'm here,
I have today off and I can come in and do this.
Yeah.
It's just fun.
It's fun to just be able to chill,
to have a day off.
That's one of the things that I kind of really scared me about doing that Scifi
show again.
It was like,
I don't want to be in that position again where I'm just like,
every minute of every day is completely filled up.
That's,
that's not,
that's not enjoyable.
You know?
It's not enjoyable to be that busy like that shit could fuck with your head at a
certain point in time.
You brain wants a break,
needs a break and you,
but then when you're working on stuff that you want to be working on it,
it's your own thing.
It doesn't feel like work at all.
It just feels,
I don't know exactly.
Something completely different and that's what it's all about.
Okay.
Going into that zone,
but then you have to stop that zone and just do nothing for a while.
Yeah.
Can only be in crazy work load it.
That's very smart of you.
You got to recover.
Cause some people don't get that and they get frazzled or then they find
Adderall.
Yeah.
No.
Then they start hating their work.
They hate what they're doing.
Yeah.
That can happen too,
for sure.
Or even worse when they're not working,
they start feeling guilty when they're not working on the time because they're
so used to that.
So even when they get a break,
that break is just riddled with this sense of despair and guilt and like,
oh fuck man,
I hope,
I hope the next job comes.
I used to totally be like that with vacations.
I can never enjoy vacations.
I couldn't just relax,
couldn't just sit around.
I think I should be doing something right now.
Yeah.
I can't enjoy vacations most.
I mean they're mostly a pain in the ass.
Especially when you travel.
Yeah.
Like a trip.
So now I think of being on vacation is staying at home and like trimming a Bush
or something like for me that's,
that's relaxing,
right?
Well that's because he's worked so much.
I think if you got tired of the same spot though,
a real vacation is fun.
Vacations are fun.
If you're going with the right people,
you know,
as long as they're not work too and you can all enjoy each other's company so
much.
You forget about the work aspect of like hug hall and all the luggage and all
the bullshit and going to the airport.
But if you could,
if you go on vacation with people that you really love and they're fun to be
with,
it's really fun.
It's a blast.
It's really fun.
And if he can get away from a place that has cell phone service,
so at least he can dip out,
you can dip out of it for a little bit.
My friends at two junky fide,
they're never going to do that.
I can't.
But you can click it.
You can pick an up place that's,
you know,
that's going to be off the grid.
Well,
my friend Steve doesn't have a phone at all.
He doesn't have,
he doesn't have a phone.
It doesn't use,
does he have a land line?
Doesn't,
you know,
his wife has phones.
She has a phone.
She actually works for Google.
It's got a hilarious,
you know,
she's dope ass Google phones and um,
he's,
he's very bright guy,
very smart guy,
but he just feels like the intrusion.
He's a professor at Stanford.
He feels like the intrusion of technology in his life is unacceptable and he
won't accept to it.
And I really loved the fact that he's like that.
You know,
it's,
it's one of those contrarion things.
It's sometimes it's annoying when people go,
I don't even have a TV.
But yeah,
this guy,
I know what he's really all about.
It really is a brilliant guy who has thought this through.
It was like,
fuck you,
my friend Brent find me every minute of every day.
Yeah.
My friend Brent Wine Bach doesn't have a phone,
a cell phone.
We only has a land line and an answering machine too.
Good for him,
man.
Look if you can pull it off.
Good for you.
I can pull it off though.
I love it.
I know sometimes I'm sitting there and hanging out with him and I'm looking at
my phone and I look over at him.
I'm like,
he's just content.
Just having his surroundings.
Just being in that.
Yeah,
he's better than us.
No,
but I'm like,
I love my phone.
I'm not going to get rid of it,
but like he wins.
Okay.
What we win because we get phones.
Yeah.
You get to be the guy that everybody talks about.
He lives on the mountain and he chops wood.
He doesn't have water.
He gets his water from the river and get the fuck out of him.
He doesn't flaunt it.
I'm not saying he flaunts it.
No,
I mean I'm not.
The guy in the mountain doesn't either.
Everybody talks about them.
Oh,
right,
so he wins because they know he's up there.
He becomes legend thousand 14.
I've been listening to that Pressfield's book,
the war of art again,
he says that checking your phone over and over again is a resistance to the
artistic impulse because you,
you can't handle the fact that you're,
all of this stuff wants to come out of you and it's painful and it comes out or
it's just intense.
So you try to avoid that by looking at your phone all the time cause it keeps
you from seeing him.
What if
Twitter is your art?
Yeah,
but is it really,
it's a very good point.
No,
for some people it is Jenny high five for her it is.
She says hilarious Shit.
Um,
uh,
any comedian who's making jokes on there and me and I was sort of making a joke
there,
but it is some truth to that.
Like my friend,
my friend slash lean.
You met her from Toronto.
W W W do you did Toronto with me.
Did you,
did Toronto just caught her in Chicago with me.
You never met her?
I haven't met her.
She's very funny.
But she's just an internet comedian.
I mean she,
she's never gone on stage.
Like she was like trying to work her way to getting on stage and doing it,
but said look,
some health problems,
she broke her hip and they have to like take some rods out of her hip was go
real thing where she can't walk for like a long time after they do the
operation,
she's putting it off.
Um,
but she's fucking hilarious and she's got a shit load of Twitter followers and
it's all just that.
So in that sense he can't be right about that cause she has like a regular job.
She does use Twitter as her art.
I think there's,
yeah of course there's some like digital artists or something just being about
semantics.
But I think that like there's a kind of processing that goes on in your life
where you're absorbing stuff,
you're seeing things and hearing things.
A lot of this stuff you don't even know you're seeing and hearing and it's
something inside of you is kind of processing.
And then when you like are always looking at the internet,
not tweeting those moments where you aren't making those great,
but what if you're absorbing barn doors and stuff that's,
that's not a bad thing.
What if you're reading things and learning new stuff because then things that
you're reading are often like you're absorbing this kind of like,
did you see how a computer generated the first news story about the earthquake?
It just spit out a news story about the earthquake.
Like it's computer and it looked like a person wrote it.
It's that easy to mimic that kind of variety,
but that kind of writing is like so empty.
It's empty calories where if you start absorbing other shit like really good
writing,
like really,
really good writing or awesome nonfiction like that.
Truman Capote,
he book in cold blood.
If you start like bringing that stuff in,
then that whatever it was processing inside of you,
those are the ingredients.
You know what I mean?
It's like you're providing yourself with richer ingredients to flavor your life
with,
to flavor,
whatever that next bout of inspiration is.
You know the next thing that comes out of you?
It.
Do you want it to be flavored with lifeless,
CNN articles about the fucking Malaysian plane disappearing.
Makes them with like read it today.
I learned that there's one chicken and Cuba.
Do you like that shit's cool,
but he got to like pepper it with some.
It's nice to have.
Oh yeah.
Then you get the book reader APP and you get in cold blood on your phone.
Well yeah.
You're talking about an audible book when you're talking about audible.com
anyway,
how amazing it is to use audible.com no,
look,
you're totally right.
You're totally right.
I agree with you,
but I don't think it's neat.
I don't think it's a one or the other thing.
I think it's both.
I think for sure there's a lot of times when I'm distracting myself when I'm
looking at my phone,
but there's other times where I'm actually like writing in a way.
Right.
You know,
because like someone will say something.
I'll say what's a funny thing to say back to that her and then I'll come up with
something like I'm exercising my create end.
I'm also interacting with people we show I think is important.
I really do.
I think
at the very least putting stuff out there,
it's like it's very important.
It's very important that people,
if someone wants to like you,
if they want to like you for comedy or they want to like you for you know,
videos that you put online and they know you and they like you actually like
you,
like you,
like they like you from you talking and they like you from you.
Writing things on Twitter,
like there's a connection there,
you know,
that I think is valuable for all of us.
You know,
I get a lot out of other people's tweets.
I get a lot out of other people's blogs.
I got a lot of other people's podcasts,
you know,
it's not just something that you and I are a part of like the distribution of
it.
We receive it a lot.
I listen to podcasts.
I was listening to radio lab all the way up here.
He ever listened to that radio lab.
And then why say it's fucking fantastic?
That's really good.
It's about,
um,
do you know that expression?
Uh,
you can neither confirm nor deny.
I heard that one.
That's a great episode.
Yeah,
it was,
wasn't,
it really is amazing.
It's that that expression came from a Russian submarine that the,
the government found and it was a nuclear submarine that sank.
The Russians couldn't find any Americans found it and they,
they pulled it out of the ocean and when they were pulling it out of the ocean,
the,
there was like a freedom of Information Act request to find out what they had
gotten or what had happened and they couldn't figure out how to deal with it
because it was in 1974 and it was post Watergate and everybody's kind of
freaking out about privacy and about,
you know,
uh,
transparency in the press and about just distribution of information that was
important and constitutional really kind of interesting in this day and age to
listen to this story.
So the CIA had a real issue because on one hand they have an obligation to keep
secrets,
especially if they think that those secrets could,
if they got out,
could somehow another endanger the safety of Americans.
So they have that on one hand.
And then on the other hand,
they had the freedom of information act that said that they had to tell the
people what was going on because they had requested is a freedom of information.
You can't hold this information back.
Did you find the nuclear submarine?
So what they said was we can neither confirm nor deny that we have found this
sub,
but we can say that hypothetically if we were to find a sub that we would not
talk about it for interest of national security,
which is hilarious.
And that became what they called a Glo Mar response because it was global marine
was the company that was pulling this,
this submarine out submarine that was by the way,
some insane like miles deep in the,
in the ocean.
Like they had to pull this fucking thing out.
It was like insanely heavy.
Something like 6 million pounds.
And they're pulling a submarine out,
like with a giant claw out of the back of a boat.
That's huge rescue mission.
They involve evolved.
Howard Hughes had to pretend that he was mining for oil there so that he could
have cover for why they're there with his giant call so that the Soviets didn't
think that they had found it and they intercepted them in the middle of their,
their extraction.
It's like a white ally without lying.
Exactly.
It's basically a way
to say yes,
but you can't say yes.
Radio Lab NYC got you guys got to download.
They're all excellent.
They're so good.
A nurse turned me onto it at this,
uh,
the clinic where I get my back treated at and she was just raving about it.
So much so that I had to check it out.
Yeah,
they're really good,
man.
They're very refined yet.
It's totally different than what we do,
but it's very nicely edited.
Yeah.
It's good.
But they do it.
The sound and the sound design.
It's really cool.
Yeah.
It's really creative,
but not intrusive.
It doesn't intrude in the story.
It doesn't intrude.
It actually picks it up.
It actually enhances it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
With podcasts,
you're getting a kind of first draft.
That's all you're getting.
You don't get,
you mean podcasts like this?
Unedited.
Yeah,
unedited podcasts are all a first draft.
And then with Twitter too,
it's like you're,
it's like a lot of what the Internet is,
is the preliminary phases of making something awesome but they never go on to
anything else.
Whereas like,
it's good to take in stuff like radio lab or stuff where people have tortured
themselves.
I don't know if they've towards you themselves with radio lab,
but you know what I mean.
We're probably have people have agonized over.
That's what standup is when you're seeing is a joke.
You're seeing something that's been refined and refined and refined and in the
process of that,
somewhere in the middle of becoming whatever it's going to become as opposed to
that first thing that just pops out.
And it seems like people are more into that first thing that pops out right now
than they are the ro,
the refining process because refining is,
uh,
is,
is not instant gratification.
Well,
it's also,
it's definitely that,
but there's a very different experience to listening to radio lab or Dan
Carlin's hardcore history,
which is another one that they put together like a show very well edited.
There's a very,
it's a big difference between those and a conversation where you're seeing the
actual thought process play out with more than one person.
You're seeing them bounce thoughts back and forth.
You Wa you feel like you're part of the conversation.
That's what's very different about something like this where they know there's
absolutely no scripting whatsoever.
They know that we're going in here and we,
we didn't know what the fuck we're going to talk about one second to the next,
but there's so much to talk about.
It's impossible to run out of material and go.
So they're watching it all sort form lot.
So even though it is sort of a first draft or in some sort of a way it off,
it provides you a very different experience in something that is polished.
When you watch an anchorman talk and tell you something on the news,
who is that guy?
Why is he talking like that?
What's going on.
Yeah.
That guy's putting on a show.
If you watch your very best friend give you that same piece of information and
the privacy of your own home,
it's much more impactful.
It's much more real.
It feels,
you know,
if a guy tells you something horrible happened on the news and he's a guy that
you don't even know if he's a fucking human,
he's wearing makeup and he's got a tie on,
why is he have to wear that outfit?
Why is that outfit so important to distribute information?
I did all I needed to be taken seriously.
We'll be right back.
Well,
you more Malaysian airline mysteries.
It seems like it used to be newscasters were more trying to fade into the
background.
You know,
they want it to be like they wanted,
they were there,
but they weren't there.
They were like talking furniture.
But now it's moving more where it's their personalities that were into,
you know,
especially on Fox News and they get those like super hot.
Uh,
of course Nancy Gray.
So I know what you're saying.
Dark in and you're out of line.
Not a space of me.
I'm a former prosecutor.
She wears those handcuffs on her neck.
Sometimes she does,
but you've seen that,
right?
It always makes me think she's,
she might be in the s and the fuck.
Yeah,
she is.
I don't really watch a lot of Nancy grace.
She's in the gluttony.
Look at her fucking piano.
I mean,
she's a tie me up with soap.
She's loves everything.
She just takes it all in.
As soon as she gets out of that stiffs tight job,
she just gets oil poured over and their toes massage and shit.
She probably just a phenom for attention.
After you try her toilet.
Paper's probably just pictures of kidnapped,
you know,
she's probably not gluten free.
The opposite,
like exclusive gluten exclusive.
What's fascinating about a show like hers or Bill O'reilly's is that they,
the personalities become like the,
the main thing.
And people want to tune in every week to see what the personalities have to say
about the news.
So it's not just about,
I'm Walter Cronkite and here's the news today,
like very professional,
but sort of impartial.
What people want is like these editorial type shows.
He's bill O'Reilly shows.
We get to hear opinions.
It's on a news channel,
but is it news?
Um,
I guess it's kind of news ish.
No,
it's a fucking opinion piece,
man.
You're telling me that during that half hour you have to talk about dead kids.
That's the only thing you could talk about.
You have to talk about dead kids every week during the same half hour.
What are you doing?
Is there a lot of shit going on in the world?
Not just one dead kid in Florida.
You keep fucking harping on.
Not that there's anything.
I mean it's important to talk about dead kids in Florida.
It's important to talk about,
especially when you're selling cars,
you got to lure people in,
man,
nothing.
We'll sell a car faster and a cliffhanger where he'd come back to find out how
the kid got raped.
How do you explain the duck tape?
All of that child's rests.
We will talk more about how baby Eugene was sodomized in Australia after this
break.
Cuts do a fucking Ford commercial.
He never go to Australia.
They don't have to.
They just data mine in Florida.
Why leave Florida?
But Florida has everything you want.
If you're CNN or Fox News.
Is anybody looking for some fucking shit to get mad about?
Have you seen that Twitter,
uh,
Florida man until,
yeah,
I'm going to Florida tomorrow.
I'm going to Miami.
It's going to be fun.
But I,
the thing that I like to think about it,
like I know that ad space costs money and so that means the story
before the ad space is making the news money.
So like when a plane crashes and some kind of way distant way,
but in some kind of way that plane crash is going to make CNN some money because
it's selling ad space and when a disaster happens,
they have more viewers watching.
So then just a regular Newsweek with general.
Yeah,
I think,
oh fuck.
Yeah.
And that's why everyone's getting angry at them.
Like Jon Stewart did like a whole,
Oh yeah.
Take off of um,
CNN and they're non news coverage of the Malaysian Airlines,
how insane it is.
Are they,
there's no news,
but they,
they'll will make new stories out of nothing just because they know you're going
to tune in.
Yeah.
And that's kind of,
it's,
it's something about that is it's like black alchemy,
you know,
it's like vulture.
It's,
yeah,
you're taking disaster and catastrophe putting it through this lens called the
news.
And at the other side you're getting paychecks and it's all email.
There's almost nothing positive on in the news.
If you stop and look at the national news,
whether it's CNN,
all they're focusing on crisis after crisis after crisis.
But that's our fault as people.
Cause that's probably what we'd look,
want to look at more honestly,
click on more.
I don't think we have enough power.
I don't think we have enough power as consumers.
I think,
um,
the,
the idea that it's our fault that they push this on television,
it's much more their fault than it is our fault.
The reason being is that one,
a,
they're profiting.
Okay.
And B,
they are choosing what to broadcast.
And when you get people in a loop,
any kind of thinking or behavior loop,
it's very hard to get them out of that loop and if they're in a fear loop,
they were in a fear,
destruction,
downfall.
The economy loop war was Syria,
this and that,
and I ran his got of that and Hitler's fucking cloned.
Yeah.
When you get in that loop,
man,
that's a hard loop to extract yourself from from,
it's like it's why ideologues on either side,
especially like on the right,
like when it comes to certain subjects,
like they lock onto those subjects and there's no wiggle room at all.
Like at least CNN will have something like doctor Sanjay Gupta turns around
totally on weed.
I mean at 180 degrees now is promoting it now is talking about all these
children that have had horrible diseases and they found cannabis is the only
cure for kids with seizures.
One kid was getting like 300 seizures a week and they got it down to one.
With marijuana.
It's Cuba was like seizuring constantly all day and the parents were helpless
watching it and marijuana curate it.
At least got it down to one minor seizure and now she's developing all these,
all this muscular control and she can walk in ways that she's never been able to
walk before.
I mean,
it's an incredible story and that would never be on Fox News.
They just,
they just wouldn't go with that.
No,
I wouldn't go with that.
No.
They found some reason why
gun control might be a good idea.
Like if there was some study that came out,
they wouldn't even be considered a debated,
you know,
it'd be just attacked,
attacked,
like you couldn't have someone come on that was like a really brilliant,
thoughtful Republican and said,
listen,
I never thought about gun control before,
but this new study tells me like maybe we do need much more stringent set of
guidelines.
It's fucking cool how if you go back and watch early Fox News howling about
Obama,
who I wished didn't blow people up with drones,
but there's some good things about him too.
You there is,
it's not all black and white,
but they were like,
this guy's going to ruin the country.
It's going to crash the economy.
We're all fucked.
Meanwhile the economy is doing much better right now.
Is that true?
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
I don't understand it.
Well the stock market's doing pretty good.
Yeah.
But I've,
I've,
I keep hearing it's inflated.
I keep hearing that there we're ready for another bubble that collapsed and
they've just sort of built up the economy.
Oh Man.
I don't know either.
That's why I'm confused.
Confusing cause you don't know how much of that is just more Fox News.
People desperately trying to ignore the fact that the worst nightmare for many
of them happened,
which is that a black man got elected and then on top of that he fixed the
crater that George Bush had put on the country.
Like when George Bush left office,
he left office like a villain and a Batman movie walking away from a buildings
that had been just trashed.
He got us into this shit war and,
and remember that you got us in this shit war for no reason.
Administration definitely was pretty fucking gross and embarrassing war and he
stood on the aircraft carrier with victory in the background.
Like having accomplished came out of a fucking helicopter is something like
drunk.
He seemed like he was drunk.
He'd been like,
snort and blow all night and then like,
fuck it,
let's,
let's have a victory celebration.
Neither confirm nor deny.
I agree with Doug on this.
I thought of a,
uh,
he's demonizing towards Bush.
It wasn't George W.
Bush.
Fuck that.
George W.
Bush was a fucking demon.
Look at that evil man.
He was an evil little wizard.
Put a black robe on that son of a bitch.
Mission accomplished.
Yeah.
Come on,
look at that guy.
Put a black robe on him and,
and it just fits.
Well,
I'll tell you what he is certainly,
I'm a classic historic figure when all sudden done it go back in time,
you know,
like they'll,
they'll go back in time and tell stories about the George Washington Cherry tree
incident and you know,
I cannot tell a lie and all that nonsense.
And then the dumbest president.
Yeah,
well he was a symbol of,
you know,
the excess of this era and we never learned from the stories of,
of history.
Like,
no one's learning from Rome.
No one's learning from the,
from,
you know,
ancient civilizations that collab due to excess,
but he's learning.
It wasn't just excess.
George W.
Bush seemed dumb and remember everyone started getting dumb.
Like not only is like country,
the whole country started getting dumb because dumb people were like,
this is
our time.
We can be presidents.
Now look,
if one of us has made it to the top,
any of us can make it to the top.
Well,
you know that one person that gets upset if you lose weight,
come on Bro.
We all got guts.
Yeah,
let's keep our gut like,
no,
I think I'm going to lose some weight,
man.
Come on Bro.
Have a fucking beer.
Don't go to the gym like a home.
All you know there's people like that and you mentioned like however you lost
it,
like whatever,
Paleo Diet,
Paleo Diet and everything you do,
that's the,
yeah,
that shit ain't good for you,
Bro.
You're going to get osteoporosis.
Yeah,
it's not good enough.
Fucking calcium.
B12 seven in there.
I think that's real similar.
I think it's real similar.
People are fucking ridiculous,
man.
They want to slow you down.
If the president's stupid look,
come on Bro.
We can be fucking stupid.
Yeah.
Be All reading and shit.
What do you will fucking reader going to ruin this crunch?
We stupid.
Fag Redone.
Yeah.
Meanwhile,
probably when the cameras were off,
he probably had a British actor,
Sam.
I was watching the fucking inside.
I'm walking dead.
Oh yeah.
They have those things where they talked to the cast members.
Rick is fucking English.
What a great actor.
He speaks in a proper English accent.
There's a moment in the show where,
and you're like,
wait a minute.
I thought you were Rick would talk like this.
Yeah.
That's a fake,
completely fake cowboy Georgia accent.
I thought he was really a southern guy.
It was so good.
I thought he was from the south.
Do you,
have you been watching walking dead?
I,
no,
I've been getting in the house of cards.
I want to do one show at a time.
I heard that shows amazing.
It's good.
Great.
Yeah.
You know what else is amazing?
I the house.
Where can people watch that?
Man?
We're going to watch your show.
Um,
if you go to youtube and just type in pound house,
it'll show up.
Do you have a website for it?
Is it just youtube or,
um,
but uh,
because we watched it on Dunkin's x-box really?
Sure.
I've never done before.
I have an APP that if you go,
if you have an iPhone,
there's an as a powerhouse app and you can watch all the episodes on the APP.
Really?
Yeah.
Why don't you make an android one bitch?
My wife fucking why only eyes?
My friend,
my friend just made it for me.
He doesn't know android,
but powerhouses that Jascha.
Yeah,
Josh is like a youtube channel network.
And then they also have this other network called [inaudible] and it's on that
one.
There's youtube channel networks.
Oh,
that's the new thing.
Whoa.
That's kind of weird.
Why don't,
I don't know how I feel about that.
I'm confused.
It's pretty cool.
I mean they fight,
it's cool cause it like they get money from somewhere to fund this crazy shit,
which is kind of awesome.
Right.
So how are they doing that?
So they're,
they're becoming like a network online.
Yeah.
Huh.
I think it's cool because,
I mean,
they,
my show probably wouldn't have happened unless someone funded,
they were like write some episodes of this
because you need that.
You need Weirdos with money to make sure to let good stuff come.
Cause like that.
If you pitch,
imagine pitching pound as to like some normal square.
Oh,
that would ruin it.
Yeah.
They'd be like,
well,
you know,
make it be like this and for this demographic and blah blah blah.
Make it more for girls.
Remember me and Duncan got that note once.
Can you skew female?
Oh,
come on,
please tell me the context.
Uh,
well,
you know,
the cool thing is it totally worked out,
which is that we were,
it's this show that is coming out on MTV other um,
at the end of April,
which is another youtube sort of like online whatever web channel called story
pig.
But we had originally pitched it to them as a show called creeps.
Creeps was the name of the show.
And we're like,
we just want to do really dark comedy sketches.
And one of the questions we got.
Oh,
they were like,
what's the show about?
Well,
it's like,
you know,
I mentioned like a serial killer.
We had like a list of stuff like serial killers.
Like what if it's serial killer made a sketch show,
like something like that.
And then the one of the things like,
cool,
we love it.
And then like next week they were like,
can you say it?
Can you skew female to make it more female friendly?
It's called creeps like creep.
What kind of conversation is that?
Like they bring you in.
Like it described to me the scenario,
are you in a room with these guys?
Like an email?
It's an email.
But then we said,
no we can't.
And what's cool is they let us do it.
And they were,
they were really cool and I didn't give us any,
they bet they didn't really give us notes that many.
They didn't give us.
No,
they were totally cool.
Super Cool.
So that was awesome.
But you get that,
that's what you get from the Internet and that's what you get.
So while you just say,
I can't,
you know,
it's not going to work.
I have to do my own thing.
And if they let you do it,
it turns out good.
Like townhouse.
I didn't get any notes or anything.
They just said,
is your episode done?
And I just turned it in.
So that's why it's so weird.
You know,
you really tell it's one guy's vision.
There was too many people involved in that.
They would,
it would get fucked up.
And it's not that it's,
again,
it's not an either or thing.
It's not that too many people.
Like sometimes a bunch of people can work together and they can produce a
masterpiece.
You know,
they just,
they just work together great.
And they know how to do it and they enhance each other.
But a lot of times a show like yours,
like the only way to really do it and have it that unique and interesting.
It's got to,
you got to have nobody fucking with you.
Can we watch an episode he didn't watch?
You?
Sure.
Can we watch the skateboard episode?
It's,
it's like kind of a music video though.
It's so funny though,
man.
We should,
but it's your shit.
If you feel weird of watching something with us,
we don't have to do it.
It's up to you.
We'll leave it up to you.
Why don't you watch it,
Dunkin,
if you think that's a good one to watch.
But which one do you think's a good one?
Did you see the one with Dunkin?
No,
I didn't.
I only saw one
very briefly.
That story.
That's more story.
The skateboard you could watch.
I only said that one cause he's,
I think people would appreciate it.
That one based on the things you've served me.
Yeah,
it's pretty good.
But I don't know man.
You know,
whatever.
How about I know p and you play whatever you want.
Yeah,
you go pee.
Go Pee.
Don't jerk off man.
That's not necessarily,
if you get tense sometimes that's the best way to handle it out.
Okay,
so what does the episode called?
What's skateboarding?
Video
powerhouse.
Skate.
Townhouse Gate.
All right,
we're going to watch this and we're going to talk shit about the listeners while
I was going on.
We'll shut her mics off and enjoy this.
All right,
and if you're a listening,
it's not as good as watching it right now.
Yeah.
Might not even work.
Oh yeah,
I forgot about this.
Is the listeners in there are people watching?
We can't show it.
You're right.
Doug,
why didn't I listen to you?
There's not,
you didn't show it.
Show the one w that urine.
Okay.
Showed you.
Which one's that?
Dinner.
Thank God.
We were thinking ahead.
What did you spend on under,
yeah,
and people say pot flux.
Were you thinking,
okay.
It doesn't at all.
Not at all.
Never has.
Not once we forgot about fucking iTunes.
We forgot about,
I forgot there was an audience.
9 million people every month.
Okay.
Okay,
let's watch it.
Cooking dinner.
It's today.
My guest on the pound cast is comedian and annoying friend Brendan Walsh.
Shots fired.
How's things with you and the lady?
She's kind of mad at me right now.
Why is she mad at you?
A ticket into my friend's mansion and she wanted to stay in it.
You know how girls get all pissed off of us stuff?
Well if you really like or you should do something special,
you should have frog come over to your house.
Cookie guys.
An intimate dinner.
Who's frog?
This frog.
He's like the number one la celebrity chef.
How am I going to get the number one Ellie celebrity chef to my house?
I'll text him right now.
You're friends with the number one la celebrity chef.
Yeah.
Frogs.
Food is totally mind blowing.
He uses ingredients that you didn't even know where ingredients.
Like what?
Like nope.
It's on for tonight.
Tonight.
Yup.
I'll be there too.
Why will you be there?
Ooh.
See you guys help frog plate the food.
Make sure you're good on refills.
Okay,
well if my girlfriend doesn't like it,
I'm going to have to.
Okay.
This is a lot of shit you people are missing if you're not watching this.
Hi.
So this is how it's going to work.
There's not going to be a manual or anything.
Frogs.
She's going to bring out the food.
It might look kind of weird,
but just eat it because trust me,
it's going to be amazing.
Awesome.
Okay,
three times.
Hi,
my name's frog.
What we have here is any poison oak salad.
It's topped with sun dried acorns.
Those are cactus needles,
sprinkles.
The whole thing has been drenched in a rattlesnake venom.
Vinegarette and here's an Amazonian Iowasca t to wash it all down.
I'm sure.
I don't know about an salad.
You're so boring was talking about you never want to try anything new.
I'll try it.
I'll try.
It looks good.
Thank you.
Oh
yeah.
You're really having to watch their eating weird food.
Yeah.
They really have to watch.
The IOS is kicking in.
It's almost over.
This bad shit.
Battered hamster tenders were amazing.
Why did you not eat any?
How's everything tasting guys?
It's so good.
Allergic to
so are you two ready for some dessert?
Yeah.
Once he got to be Maggie cake close.
It's chocolate cake.
Oh,
it looks actually kind of good
stuff on top that seaman frogged all over before I brought it out.
I'm sorry.
My friend says stupid.
Well,
you know what?
I don't think it's working out between you two,
right?
You know what?
I think you're right.
You want to go get a burger?
Oh,
okay.
We're done.
That's no
fun.
It's fine.
It's basically over
one more part.
Oh Shit.
I'm ready for my dance.
That's somebody's watch.
I'll peer the music watching all that play out on him.
So that's a new addition.
What you guys are listening.
Yeah.
And
you gotta watch it cause it's so much of it is so weird.
David Lynch like and just cool.
Lynchian I believe it's very,
very visual,
but really,
uh,
distinctly you like,
you could really see like the same vision,
the same sense of humor in every episode.
It's really fun.
Thanks man.
You know,
that's one of the cool things about something like that where one guy is doing
the whole thing.
I got to give it up to Brent wine back cause he kind of,
he's kind of like my co writer on it.
So he's hilarious.
He's hilarious.
That character.
She plays it.
So sorry.
I love that one line.
Whether you in the,
I was telling him the,
the line,
when you're doing the open mic in your living room,
we should collaborate together.
Oh,
that's what's up
in the context of that fucking strange character.
And you're watching him for a couple episodes in a row.
It's like all my God,
I couldn't stop giggling.
It's really,
really funny stuff,
man.
Man,
I think that TV is he just going to get better and better because the staff like
that because it creates competition and people they can,
they get to see what's happening without the big risk because when you're making
a TV show,
there's so much risk involved that you can't really,
there's so much money at stake rather than it is to take a big risk is insane.
You want to just go by the median,
what then like middle of the road because that's going to sell the most
advertisements,
but when they start seeing people actually liked stuff like that and respond to
it than TV is just going to keep,
hopefully we'll get better.
Well,
it's,
the Internet has changed the whole fucking game because the same people that
watch the Big Bang Theory Watch decapitations,
you know,
it's like the same people.
The same people watch Kim Kardashian sex tape.
Same people will.
It's just humans.
All right.
Just give humans act as to what they want,
you know,
and when you limit shit because you think somehow or another it's going to
bottleneck the amount of money you're able to suck out of a show.
All you're doing is you're limiting how many people are gonna Watch that thing.
Yup.
I want to see decapitations on that Big Bang theory.
That would be amazing.
I can imagine that she ended it like a red wedding.
Fuck.
All the characters are and they all have their own guillotine.
Yeah,
like 12 g and teens all lined up and just be great.
The,
I'll just get kidnapped somehow by like a real actual killer who's like doesn't
understand what they're saying.
He doesn't even speak English.
He's thinking he doesn't even get their jokes.
Just starts chopping their hands off and their feed off.
He's crying while he's doing it.
That'd be so great.
It would be so artistic and beautiful and wonderful.
It's that.
That's what's weird about like bill O'Reilly or the Big Bang theory or any of
those shows is they have this perfect opportunity at any moment to blow people's
minds by just making 180 degree turn.
Just turning in some complete opposite direction.
But imagine if bill had
direct an episode of Big Bang theory.
No notes.
Yes.
It's going to be a lot of activity.
You'd have to write it to.
You couldn't know I can I,
if I,
if I have creative liberties with the script and if I can get any as my and many
gay teens is,
I want God,
that'd be so fun.
That'd be so fun.
If like they had to do that at once a year.
They had to let underground artists edit and direct their shows just to see what
it would turn into.
Yeah.
Why?
That would be a terrible idea.
Be Fun.
Yeah.
It'd be fun for you,
but match those stakes shows like sitcoms,
you know,
it's not low stakes because imagine if it was your show and then some fucking Dj
Doug pound comes on and he's like,
I'd like to direct your show for a week and be like,
fuck you man,
we're going to kill your whole cast.
No,
you're not man.
No.
Who wants to watch that shit?
Listen man,
trust me.
Seven 18 it's going to be awesome.
They wake up and it's all a dream though.
That's the,
that's the caveat.
Blossom becomes a demon.
Yeah.
They all start eating babies.
Ah,
baby salad every day.
But we'll just use like rubber baby dolls.
Don't worry.
But if bill O'Reilly came out for one show in drag
and just it's like this is who I am now.
It doesn't really explain it.
Same Guy and he's the same guy.
He's just like,
this is who I am.
This is how I've changed deal with it.
That would be as
big as GE are,
be as big as Jesus.
That is how Jesus will come back.
It will be below right now.
Wilamena we'll Amena O'Reilly and he starts slowly beginning a transformation
until to the female gender.
Yeah,
that would be incredible.
It just tells you like the reason why he was like that.
It was just,
he was scared.
I was scared all the time that people find out that he identifies with being a
woman and that's where all the hate came from,
the homophobia,
all the Jesus' love,
all that craziness that was,
he was into.
It's really just,
I wanted to be a woman and then he just starts putting pictures of his new
surgical crusty bill O'Reilly pussy up on the screen and people just itch,
causes waves of suicide.
But here's what's crazy.
People still spot him out at night,
like dress like a man and he looks perfectly normal and they realize it's just a
fucking scam.
Like everything else he does.
He's not really becoming a woman.
It's just a bullshit artist.
That would be one of the greatest salvage.
No,
it's what happens is you realize someone's blackmailing him.
You realize somebody has something worse than that and they're like,
listen,
bill,
that's like a house of cards move.
Here's what I want you to do on your show.
What do you think?
Oh my God,
I've got these pictures of you fisting
pansy change the chimps wanted.
I was doing it for Jesus.
Tie goes in and tide goes out.
You don't know why.
I just chimps
who can explain it.
God moves in mysterious ways while their fist and they did.
Or I don't wear a dress.
You fucking Cock sucker,
but I'm not.
When I go out.
That's my deal.
My personal life.
Yeah.
It's so,
it's so fascinating,
man.
And that's the descent.
That's it.
It's like deceptive.
I get it with artists and actors,
they don't have to reveal their personal lives to anybody.
They don't.
They don't have to.
But when you have someone who's an actor like bill O'Reilly,
and we don't know who he is or what he's really like,
but when you have somebody who's an actor portraying themselves in this way,
is this unchanging?
Just monolith of of conservativism then it's,
I think it's,
it's not fair because you know that guy's got serious fucking problem.
Yeah.
But doesn't bill O'Reilly think doesn't,
he doesn't think of himself as an actor.
He doesn't,
I don't think that's being him.
He thinks he's being,
or maybe he is,
you know,
genuinely being just who he thinks he is.
Certainly.
Uh,
there's certainly moves.
He did certainly makes moves.
Like the whole tag goes into tacos out thing.
The guy went to Harvard.
Okay.
He's not an idiot.
He knows fucking gravity causes that.
He knows the moon because he knows that he knows.
So when he's saying shit like that,
you can't explain that he's,
he's trolling,
he's getting ratings and he's getting ratings.
Is getting people on his team.
I mean he,
he,
he most certainly is.
Do you think it's possible that the whole missing Malaysian airlines thing was
the plane was hijacked by CNN for ratings?
I don't know that a possibility to Dunkin the money
follow the money.
Who made the most money off this Malaysian plane crash scene and there it's
definitely CNN.
CNN is raking in the dough.
Everybody who like had those last moments of like plunging into the ocean,
looking at the person next to them screaming,
registering that this truly is their last moment in this dimension.
They're spirits can take comfort knowing that they didn't die for nothing.
CNN has made probably $300,000 on that plane.
It never existed.
And those people in the plane never existed.
They were completely fabricated names
and that plane will never be found.
It was an enlist
endless amount of,
you know,
completely preposterous.
But you know that that was actually what they proposed during operation
Northwoods.
What is that?
What was that one in north document was the thing that they,
uh,
the,
the Joint Chiefs of Staff signed and uh,
President Kennedy vetoed and the idea was to fake a bunch of attacks on America
to blame on the Cubans.
And one of their ideas was to take a drone airliner and they were going to say
that a bunch of people were on board and then they take the people off and they
put them in buses and they shuttle them off to somewhere cause they fucking
finagle people who work for the government in the 1960s every bunch of fake
names.
Fly the plane up in the air and explode it,
blow the plane up.
And then they were going to have like fake relatives like Ooh I lost a little
Billy.
Meanwhile a little Billy doesn't even exist standard with a real person.
So this plane blows up cause it's a drone.
And then they were going to arm Cuban friendlies and have them attack wanton
them obey and they're gonna use all this.
Blame it all on Castro's.
We can invade man.
I listened and that reminds me of your awesome joke.
I,
it's an old joke.
But the thing about like,
like if we ran it like a Roman emperor,
if we just decided,
you know like that's,
it's like the empire is hogtied right now because it's got to pretend to be a
democracy.
So it's got to come up with shit like that instead of what they used to be able
to look.
It could have done back in the old days,
which is there wouldn't even,
it wouldn't be a question.
Yup.
You just go take the island.
We were scared because then they would also take us,
you know like we,
we need,
we need a populace that is very complacent and we need a populace that's
terrified of violence.
Even though violence is like super important in order to keep control of the
populace.
But we need a,
we need a populace that's looking for civilization.
We don't need a fucking tiredly armed group of 300 million savages that are
ready to fuck people up and take their oil.
That's the last thing we want.
So we want some sort of surrogate taking the oil and some people that we know
there are heroes and they're over there somehow are involved in oil,
freeing people free and people from their need to pay more for oil or control or
whatever the fuck it is.
But as long as the general population is wearing a nice ties and listening to
the men on the news and not freaking out and wanting to cut his throat,
as long as they're not all going fucking barbarian Mongol style.
Because once they start killing
a few people kill a little here,
killed a little there and people get used to it.
They get used to a pretty God damn easy.
And then they start thinking about these cons that are running the government.
They start thinking about the shitheads like abusive cops.
You see that video that,
uh,
the thing in a,
was it Arizona,
Arizona riot,
this caught blind sides.
This kid,
a little girl.
What young girl?
Oh,
play it.
It's fucking horrific.
So fuck that.
That cop,
what happens to you?
I don't know.
We'll find out,
but what,
what I'm getting from people that were there,
a lot of people that were there tweeted at it,
they were saying the kids were definitely out of control.
Kids were drunk.
It was getting at,
but he was saying that the cops seemed like they were enjoying fucking people
up,
like they were running around and just randomly fucking people up.
And uh,
a lot of people have a real problem with that.
A lot of people have a real problem with they're,
they're not,
they're not finding like the dangerous people.
Look at that.
Oh,
that girl that mean,
come on man.
How,
how is that even possible?
Watch that again.
There's a little girl,
I mean,
she's not big at all,
man.
I don't know what she could have done,
but that cop just blind sides her and sensor over a bike rack.
I mean,
that is fucked.
There's no way on earth that guy needed to do that.
There's no way.
The only way would be if that woman was coming at him with a weapon or coming at
someone else with a weapon and he was saving someone's life.
What he just did there is like either some PTSD that he's like,
he's fucked or he's a sadist or whatever the fuck it is.
That guy does not need to be a cop.
They need to remove that guy.
That's,
there's no way a man in that position of power should be able to do that.
That woman was not a threat.
He was a big guy.
She was a small woman.
There's no way that she had a reason that he should have done it.
Maybe he's a time traveler and at that moment she was at Baptist meet this guy
and that he was going to get her pregnant with the next antichrist.
So he knew that if he just slammed her down,
that once he might've saved millions of people's,
you might be right.
He might be in jail right now,
handcuffed behind his back.
Speaking in tongues.
Yeah,
you're,
you can only like stay in this time for like a couple of days to you start going
crazy.
Yeah.
The,
yeah.
The further you get away from your original timeline,
the more insane you get.
Spacetime continuum just fries your hard drive and like that.
I was happy to do,
I don't want to hurt you.
Bad guys fucking handcuffs and speaking in tongues.
What's that famous time traveler?
I'm sorry,
I didn't mean to derail John t door.
Yeah.
Jayanti door.
It's all bullshit.
I know it's bullshit.
There's a famous time traveler,
but it's a great story.
It said bullshit if you think it's real,
but it's a story.
It's cool man.
Because the way he dealt with the,
the way he dealt with going back and killing your grandfather or whatever the
way paradox is by saying that,
it's like there's multiple timelines and you can go back in time.
You're not on the exact
same timeline that you are on.
And so things are slightly different in that timeline.
So t door would say that like he would get colds all the time here.
Like colds were a little worse in this dimension.
This guy,
he said he was from another time.
It's a time traveler folks.
He's a fucking writer.
He's a writer,
is not a bad one,
not a bad one at all.
And he wrote something that he thinks would be a fun troll and he came up with
this,
uh,
he's got a patent file for John teeters time machine,
like an asshole.
If anybody ever says like,
Hey,
well there's a patent for it,
you know,
it must be real.
You need to go and look at what a goddamn patent is.
Shut your mouth.
Because there's a lot of fucking patents.
There's patents for all sorts of ridiculous shit.
There's,
or at least a pull applications patent pending time travel or go back in time
and patent everything.
Yeah.
How come you going back in time when you got to just fucking everybody with your
knowledge from the future?
Yeah,
the whole thing's ridiculous.
But the idea of a bunch of different timelines is actually not that ridiculous.
Well,
they're saying now with that new discovery that apparently it doesn't,
it like point to the idea that there's a multiverse or bubbled universes or
something,
inflation theory,
whatever that new discovery is.
There's so many of these,
I don't know,
I wouldn't say competing theories,
but ultimately they're all just,
they're there.
They're sort of coincide that you don't know.
You don't know like who's right,
who's wrong or whether or not they're all right and that there's like a billion
different examples of what a universe is or an infinite number of examples of
what could take place at any different timeline.
They say that infinity is so intense like the idea of infinity and this is the
best way to wrap your head around it.
If infinity Israel,
that means that in the universe not only has everything that we've said in the
exact same order and the exact same pauses in the exact same
timeframe and fuck up of words or slip of the tongue,
it's happened exactly that way in exactly that order.
An infinite number of times,
not just one,
but an infinite number of times that everything that's ever taken place down to
the millisecond has not just happened once somewhere else,
but infinite times somewhere else.
Wow.
That's how big infinity is.
That's what no end means.
That's so weird.
Like it just like when you're doing some mundane thing like jerking off,
coming to porn,
just thinking this is infinite infinite loop of jazz that's happening.
Oh,
shins,
oceans of jazz.
You could just see like just a universe filled with you squirting ah,
fractal.
Like literally a universe that's real.
Like so the sky would be absolutely filled from horizon to horizon with with you
coming more than this.
It's
all the come from all the Dunkin's in all over the world.
At once.
Drench the earth.
We would drown in semen.
Oh,
how's the entire population would drown.
We would be coded in like a million miles thick of com because if you think
about what infinity means,
how many different Dunkin's would be coming,
there's no end to it.
So one ounce of calm equals 100 billion oceans filled with come instantaneously
raining down upon those oceans would be filled with more me's coming.
Not only that,
the universe itself would not be big enough to contain the earth size.
Just from the sheer amount of calm it was covered it.
It would push the atmosphere way past the sun.
It would light the earth on fire and turn it into a big come one of those.
What are those fucking hush puppy.
It was a big come hush puppy when the come got so big it touch the sun in a deep
fryer just so big.
It touches the sun and then puts the sun out and presses out into the outer
galaxy.
That's how much com infinite amount of people coming and then some like you,
some God chef would just come and eat it.
It's just not a cooking show and,
and then you know,
he lives in another world where you're coming on and it just goes on forever.
No,
that's how you impregnate the sun.
You fill a planet with come to the stop up a black hole.
We don't know what to do about a black hole.
We're going to get an infinite amount of Dunkin's to come in it.
Well,
it's,
you know,
mass broken down to the smallest part.
Uh,
it's not going to stop an infinite amount of come.
Trust me.
Well,
there's a whole nother university side.
They're still not big enough for infinite amounts of calm.
Sorry.
The black holes.
Like what the fuck please?
Top comm
the black polos like Sasha gray with the fucking giant black cock being force
fed while she's lying on her back.
Snots going down into her eyelashes.
That's the universe.
Yeah,
it'd be so symbolic.
So some bog of gag porn,
you're coming into a black hole.
Those,
the fucking whole event horizon starts sputtering.
No,
that's spinning.
The spinning of the black hole absorbing matter just gets all choked up like a
fucking,
like a,
like a dishwasher disposal system with a spoon in it.
You know when those garbage disposals,
the spoon drops in it
and you're scared to put your hand in there to try to unstop it,
do you think,
and that's how the universe was created.
His infinite come and if it come loop went into a black hole.
Do you think that ever ever come into a black hole in the future?
Oh yeah.
If we live long enough,
someone's
going to want to do that.
I think.
I don't want to be the first guy.
Some Richard Branson type asphalt.
What do you mean the first guy to show the world?
I want to inspire you,
but you two can come in a black hole.
Him with a fucking black socks on.
So I always come,
he sends like a shuttle from his pod.
Yeah.
And he's got like,
it's like a glory hole into the next shuttle and he's wearing an aqua man t
shirt.
It's way too small and he's
a little,
slightly embarrassing roll of fat pulls out of the Bar,
like a little waterfall.
It's just jerking off with his black socks on into it until black.
Hey,
you never know til you try.
I seek to inspire.
I'm seeking to inspire you that you too humble man.
Um,
him.
You see,
did you edit the Tim and Eric Sketch the universe?
What is that called?
The one where they're talking about space.
I don't think I did.
God funny you seen that man?
No.
Can you,
can you pull up to the 10 minute,
what's it called?
Space.
Just the universe.
The universe.
This is one of the funniest fucking one.
This is one of my favorite comedy sketches.
Really good.
All right.
Yeah,
the universe.
What a concept.
You know the universe is a little bit like the human hand.
For example,
you have Grumman's center right here and then you have undiscovered worlds and a
sector eight and up here it's a Tillman's crest so you can be,
can kind of picture that it's a little bit like a leaf or it's not a bowl.
The Universe is beautiful.
Something like a new woman that I was going to date.
You're dark and your your massive and you have a black hole.
All of those elements I want to explore just like you would explore on a new
date is facial expression.
He's been to that and feel around and just see,
see what's going to come out of that.
The time it takes to get from one star to another star is in c you need to
travel at the speed of light.
And I'll assume as,
can't even fathom the concept of that kind of time because it's really,
really,
really fun
light ride.
Ah,
if you could put the universe into a two,
you'd end up with a very long too.
You've got to watch this folks doing twice the size of the universe because when
you collapsed the universe,
it expands.
And it would be,
you wouldn't want to put it into a tube
picture of a hot dog bun and through all the stars,
the hundreds of stars that there are in the universe,
into a pet,
into a bag and put the universe into a bag.
And you all of a sudden they become,
um,
uh,
I was a child,
but there are now
90 planets,
you know,
the ultimate fate of the universe.
So dark and mysterious that it generates butterflies in my stomach and that goes
to tickles in my spine.
And that creates goose pimples.
And then that penetrates my mind.
And then the,
the whole big banks.
Ooh,
ah,
no,
stars can be fun.
A lot of people say,
Donna,
you get so wrapped up in the physics of it.
Don't you have any fun?
I say,
well,
I go up and I look at the stars through my telescope and I see the little
dumpster,
or I see the big dip stir.
Every star has,
it's has a sister starr,
a little bit like two eyeballs.
If you can imagine,
if,
if you could see the other side of my eyeball,
you'd see a 360 degree eyeball.
Do you know that when you look at a planet and you see that light,
that plan,
it's not even there.
That's just a light.
That's just your neighbor shine the flashlight right in to your yard.
Fuck looking for coons.
And he says,
what are you doing in my backyard with that flashlight?
And I told him,
I'm shining.
I'm shining in your window so I can teach your son about the universe.
He said,
get out of my yard and why are you communicating to my son?
Why are you in all black behind my bushes?
Shining a light into my house and I said,
I'm teaching your son about the universe.
I'm shining a light,
shiny light right in there and exploring his room as he's looking out and
exploring the universe.
I turned the light off and I see your son go to bed and I turned the light back
on and I do swirls on his wall like a comet's tail.
I do this every night.
It's your son.
Fuck man.
Fuck.
Oh my God.
There's so weird
that those guys have the weirdest style.
Yeah.
It's uh,
it's such an interesting style of comedy because you really have no fucking idea
where they're going.
It's very refreshing because it's really hard to watch something where you,
even if it's well written,
he know where it's going.
Like you know where everything's going.
Yeah.
How long did you work on that show,
man?
For the whole time.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's fun.
That's so cool.
He's so lucky to have been on that show.
That was like a,
that was like,
I don't know,
I,
it reminds me of,
of Monty python or something or like a more modern version of that.
You know,
it's just such a revolutionary.
It's a revolutionary show and that's a gross word.
Use.
Everybody hates it is,
it is.
You're right,
cause it's so
far out there that it's like it push it.
Like you know,
that's,
that challenges people to not be so stuck in like normal square types of
sketches.
That's why I love writing with you man.
Because you're always like pushing it so far outside of where I would go with
it.
Well you know,
you got to try to do something different.
Yeah.
You have to,
in this day and age to so many premises have been beaten to death,
especially when you're dealing with like human interactions.
Like how many Goddamn sitcoms are there been?
How many movies are that have been,
how many,
how many dramatic shows that have comedic scenes?
I mean,
how much,
how many subjects can be covered the same way over and over again.
You know,
after a while it's like,
oh my fucking God.
Yeah.
It's weird too when you start thinking about like how much of what I'm doing and
how much of what I'm saying day to day is original and how much of it is just me
regurgitating something I heard yeah.
Before.
Well,
there's definitely gonna be some of that.
Oh ways that,
I mean that is the,
the big knock on the concept of flip of plagiarism.
You know,
the,
the knock on,
you know,
when someone accuses,
especially Comedians,
plagiarism,
essentially,
there's no way anybody has a unique thought and if you have a unique thought,
it is merely a combination of your thoughts and all the knowledge that all the
human beings before you have left behind,
including the language that you're communicating in every single idea that
formulates this thought,
every single piece of information that's been accumulated long before you were
ever born,
most likely.
And that's what's led to this being able to talk.
The difference being,
of course,
differences use someone who kind of acknowledges that but comes up with it on
their own and someone who just sits around and waits for other people to come up
with it and then steals those ideas because would they are as a fake antenna?
You're not,
if you're not an antenna,
you like an agent,
you're like you're stealing the actual creative idea instead of tuning into it.
Yeah,
and we like it when we find someone like a Joey Diaz,
like someone who's just tuning into it,
he figured out how to tune into it and that Sam and you like to be around him
because he says funny shit all the time.
Yeah.
And then someone else who just waits to hear what Joey Diaz says and then just
repeat it.
Okay.
Dude,
when I was at,
I used to,
I go to a summer camp and I remember talking to this kid and he was telling me
about is like we got to kind of be frenzy.
Tell me about his like childhood.
And I remember it seemed weirdly familiar and then I was thinking about it and
he live,
he told your story of your childhood yet?
I'd be fucking weird.
No,
he lifted it from a movie,
like some,
I can't remember what it was,
but he like kind of went into details and he had just lifted it from a movie
that he saw.
He was just sort of,
oh my God,
it was okay.
Hey,
that's
all kids learn how to be themselves.
Yeah.
This kid,
they get to make it.
Yeah,
I think you're right man.
I think it's okay.
Nothing weird about it at all.
Not at all.
Except when we were like,
I remember like swimming at free swim and he did this awful thing.
This is like the end of our summer camp friendship because I had already like
found out that he'd been like he'd been lying about,
um,
his childhood,
which is already kind of weird.
But then we were like swimming back to shore and I remember he stuck his ass out
of the water.
He'd pulled his shorts down and he stuck his ass out of the water and like
pulled his butt cheeks apart to like moon.
Everybody in one way belongs in a zoo.
People logs in an asylum.
Like,
what was this awful kid like?
Why was he doing this?
He's lying about his childhood.
He's like hard buying everyone.
It's like saying it's a cry for help when people pull their bug apart.
It's like that's what it is,
that they read your palm,
they tell you that and that kid drowned and then his mom came back and killed
everybody.
That camp,
it
was just named Jason.
I knew that kid
was the story from a famous movie.
I can't remember the movie,
but I remember thinking about it later and realizing like,
oh,
he lied that that,
that's definitely from a movie like it was.
I mean I was probably,
I wasn't idiot.
I am an idiot.
But like then I was especially,
I don't have a kid.
I'm an idiot,
but like a 27
that's such an easy joke when anyone asks me that says it's,
it's funny.
Look,
it's good.
It's good.
It's there.
It doesn't,
just because it's easy doesn't mean it's not good.
Um,
no,
I was probably,
let's see,
I was in cabin three I guess.
I don't know,
cause at a Christian camp,
well,
it wasn't a Christian camp,
but they did have church on Sundays and stuff,
but it was cool.
I mean it wasn't like they were like beating you over the head whether it was a
girl.
I went to that camp and became a camp counselor.
That camp,
this is Camp Pinnacle in North Carolina and I went to that camp since I was like
probably nine or 10 and just kept going back every summer.
That stuff's good for kids,
man.
Getting away from home,
hanging out with like other people being outdoors.
And I think this camp now,
I think Camp Pinnacle now that won't let kids keep cell phones there.
So when you come,
the kids have to put,
you have to give up your phone.
Wow.
That's probably good for some kids.
I went to a camp that was not good for kids.
It was dangerous.
It as a bunch of little criminals.
I went to a,
it was Jamaica plain,
which was a kind of a sketchy area in Boston and it was the boy scout troop.
When you went to New Hampshire for two weeks,
kids are at tying kids up and taking their fucking cots and leaving them in the
woods because it was pitch black at night.
They tried to do it to me,
to what?
I woke up fucking yelled at them and people would pour toothpaste.
All everybody,
one's close like it was like very fucking sketchy,
like there's a little criminal camp and so I would just disappear every day and
go fishing.
I didn't do any of the activities.
I just got the fuck out of there.
I remember up bullet ricocheted by me once.
It was only at 22 but
there was a shooting range and someone hit a rock and a bullet fuck up like we
heard the polo.
What the fuck is that?
Someone goes,
it's a ricochet.
I was like a fucking ricochet.
I could,
we can get hit by bullets.
We can get hit by bullets,
and they were like,
no,
we can get hit by bullets.
I'm like,
I am so fucking adding here.
And so every morning I would just take off and go fishing.
So for two weeks I went fishing and they even know I was gone.
Like they barely paid attention.
I went to band camp you place was ruthless man.
Like I was a freshman in high school.
Day One,
they're like off like on your way in that,
you know,
you're getting all these warnings.
Like you know,
every freshman gets their underwear ripped right out of their pants by the
seniors.
They're going to raid your cabins.
It was scary.
I was like,
I was hiding under the cab,
under the bunk and uh,
one of the guys was a sympathetic to me.
He let me go.
Really?
Wow.
So they were trying to do that though.
They were trying to pull everybody.
I was like extra small.
They're like,
we can't pick on this kid,
Tim.
That's a good way to get stabbed.
Somebody gets really mad at you fucking,
you can pull underwear on the wrong kid and he waits till you're asleep and
sticks up for help your ass.
So people are so grows.
The fact that that you give like that,
that's an obvious supervision issue.
Like you can't just leave older kids with younger kids,
there's too much of a tendency to bully you.
Just key.
You don't know those kids.
And these are young kids and you'll like trusting of some fucking 11 year old
around some 16 year old like don't do that.
Like you don't,
there's always one cut head.
16 year old is going to do stupid shit to kids and if your 11 year old son is
around some 16 year old boys,
they're probably going to smack him around or do something fucked to him.
You know,
it's just,
it's a bad supervision issue.
Yeah,
that is all it is.
It's all it is.
And when I was there,
I was 11,
uh,
in Florida or in Jamaica plain rather.
I was like 11 or 12 because I had moved,
I lived in Florida from um,
11 actually 13.
I was probably 13 because I live in Florida from 11 to 13 and when I was 13 is
when I lived in Jamaica Plain.
So that's definitely how old I was.
And you know,
these kids were like 17 there was like some,
some kids that were like eagle scouts there were older.
And for them it was like this wild vacation thing and they would get away and
just fucking torture.
Kids get crazy and she rocks and stuff and that's sacks.
It was fucking sketchy as hell,
man,
because it wasn't that many like people running it like you looked around and
how many kids there were and he looked at how many counselors there where it's
like,
whoa,
there's like fucking 20 kids through each person that is in boy scouts.
Kind of like mo Millie militant about like barely.
They just don't want gays.
It's all to keep the gaze out and just fucking have at it.
Well,
at least what with a camp that I went to,
I mean they had some things that you did,
like you met for breakfast and you know they had activities that you were
supposed to be doing,
but I wasn't fucking dude.
That was like about keeping people in line,
like scout's honor and all that stuff.
Not at night,
man.
The guy goes to sleep.
No,
it's fucking kids are running around time people up.
I mean that was just reality.
It was,
it was fucking dangerous.
You want to send your kid to camp,
that's old.
That's the like findings.
Cause there's
some camps that are all like this camp was,
I think it was,
it was 80 or a hundred years old.
It had been around for a while and they knew how to do it many,
many summers and there's traditions and there's people who've been there and he
was kind of sounds scary or actually,
I mean it's like some old time shit like Joe's old camp,
Bohemian Grove type shit.
Well No,
I mean there,
yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
Like there was a fee.
There were like,
there was like,
you know like there were traditions there.
There was like I was old and there it did.
You know who the fuck knows.
It did have that.
Whenever I look at,
I swear to God when I see videos of the Bohemian Grove,
I think it can't pinnacle.
I always think I'm like,
oh that's just a summer camp for tyrants.
That's what the Bohemian Grove is.
It's clearly just a summer camp where you go to if you're an oil billionaire,
what is this?
Oh Wow.
Look at what is it?
What are they doing?
I asked Duncan.
I don't know.
That wasn't there when I was there.
It looks like some sort of a wrestling match or a game or something.
No,
that's that's,
this is where you would have the kids fight and the survivor
teach you about heart.
It's what I'm here.
I'm here to make a man out of you,
doctor.
Yeah.
My camp,
I don't remember what the fuck it was called.
I just remember it was in New Hampshire and at nighttime it,
it was a,
there was no moon out one night when we were there and I couldn't believe that
it could get so dark that you couldn't see your hand in front of your face.
You put your hand from your face.
You literally couldn't see it.
Couldn't say it was so dark.
It was unbelievable how dark got at night.
How could you see the kids you're trying to tie up?
That's the problem.
These content flashlights,
he's a little fuck heads.
Had flashlights and you,
you'd hear footsteps and flashlights and giggles and they actually know someone
was touching you in the middle of the night and you're like,
get the fuck off me and scream and yell and you got,
you had a scream and yell.
Cause if you just tried to play it like play cool.
Come on guys.
They'd fucking gag you.
Tell you tighter sounds terrible.
It was not good.
It was definitely not good for me because being a 13 year old around 17 year
olds is Zoe's sketchy dudes are dickheads,
you know,
especially if you give them enough leeway,
you give enough room,
they don't know any better and they're just getting,
especially if they have older brothers that fuck with them.
That's a big one,
man.
That's a real big one.
If you run into some kids that have older brothers that beat them up,
there's a good chance that they're going to have some pent up resentment and
looking to get there is in on someone else.
All right.
That's what they say about abuse.
So a lot of kids that abused their kids,
they got abused and it's just sort of,
it just passes on generation to generation.
How do you stop that cycle?
Yeah,
it's good question.
I have a third party intervene during their teenage years or something.
There's probably some counseling ways that you could do it.
Some ways of recognizing what sort of a pattern you've fallen to.
You want to look at yourself.
If you're an abuser and recognize that you actually are the crest of the wave of
the universe and you have a chance to stop this disease that affected you from
spreading into infinity,
you can stop it.
I think that's what it takes.
The,
the people who are doing it,
I have to wake up to the fact that they can actually transform everything if
they just stop this terrible flow of shit.
It's been going through from like just some asshole 200 years ago,
punched his kid and then that kid punched his good and that kid punched his get.
It's like an echo of this shitheads punch traveling through town to the punch.
Someone could block it.
Yeah.
We didn't start punching our wives,
but we can stop
gum for sure.
This is a very unique time and that we're really aware of the repercussions of
all this stuff and the recidivism repercussions and the fact that it translates
from one generation to the next.
We're aware of that I think more than ever before.
And there's more of a backlash against it than ever before.
And you could clearly see that just about abuse in movies.
How about like abuse of,
of women?
I used to be normal for the lead of a movie to smack a woman in the face and it
was okay.
It was like a man.
He's a man's man.
Get a hold of yourself right in the kisser.
I think Louise,
start again.
Louis C K is like opening monologue on SNL.
One of the things he said was like,
there is a are,
you know,
an article of clothing,
like a wife beater shirt.
There's a article of clothing which is based the beating your wife,
is it that offends?
Like you could just say that no one cares.
That crazy.
Yeah.
Ever even thought of that is so true.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
It is crazy man.
But you know,
like what I like sometimes a wife beater tee shirt.
I got the boxer,
a lot of violent clothing.
Boxer briefs.
Yeah.
But they just look like boxer shorts.
Why Feeder?
It's like,
I know,
I know.
I just upon um,
it would've been good if you started with boxer and then we worked up to
wifebeater Peter Wife beaters.
Definitely the closer though
the the,
you know,
when you're like,
sometimes you'll find yourself habitually being an asshole.
Like sometimes like I'll,
I'll find myself like being a jerk to someone like an,
and then I in my head,
my mind will register,
oh,
I'm acting like my mom right now.
And like my mom was,
you know what I mean?
Like,
Oh shit.
Oh Shit,
this is a habit I picked up from somebody else that I'm [inaudible] that I'm
pushing through time.
See.
And the idea is like,
when you recognize not everyone,
of course,
it's not all just violence and punching people.
It's not all,
sometimes it's not so overt.
Sometimes the thing you're doing is just mildly conti,
you know what I mean?
But it's still something you learned from someone who is mildly conti to you.
It's like you could stop that.
You can actually stop that by going against the habit because sometimes you'll
realize I'm being this way for no reason,
but I still want to be this way because I feel comfortable acting this way.
You know,
just,
it's just a habit.
It's just a comfortable habit.
Don't,
I don't think they feel comfortable.
I think they just feel they don't know how to
not feel like that or how did they track?
Scrapped.
Yeah.
Cause that's the word,
right?
It is trapped.
I mean that's really what it is.
You're in a like a gambling thing.
You ever met a guy who's got a real gambling thing.
It's like they're trapped in this pattern or thinking cause whatever rush they
get out of that,
it's like undeniable.
And some people they get trapped and like almost seeking this rush of anger or
this rush of,
you know,
being perturbed or just getting fucking frustrated with things and then they
fall into that pattern and they just get trapped there.
But I think we,
we know that now more so than ever before.
And it's like the lessons like you and I for sure learned something from what
our parents did wrong.
We,
we certainly learned something from our parents did right.
But we definitely also learned something from what our parents did wrong.
And I think our children,
my children,
you,
if you ever have children,
are going to hopefully learn from shit that I do wrong to like things that
affected them that I said to them that maybe I shouldn't have said that they're
gonna,
they're gonna compartmentalize.
They're going to think about it more when they have a kid.
They're going to be one step ahead of me,
you know,
hopefully,
I mean,
I'm doing my best,
but we're just human beings and the process is ongoing and culture is evolving
along with generation to generations learning all these lessons.
I mean,
our actual human culture,
it's just way more advanced and way more sensitive than it wasn't the 1950s
that's why he could have a movie where the lead guy smacks a woman in the mouth,
get a holiday or south smack smack.
Whereas the guy today would go,
hey,
you know,
this is not necessary.
Just relax.
We're going to get through this.
All right,
let's just talk about why you're upset.
You're like,
that's what a normal person would do.
Like you don't have to hit her.
You don't have to Hook,
get a holiday as tough SPEC.
That is so weird.
That used to be like a cure,
like snacking with,
Oh and then you fuck the shit out of her.
Cause that's what she really wanted.
She wants you to just show you care.
Give her a couple up fucking knuckles across the mouth.
A little bit of blood.
Just a little,
just enough to get her hot when you're kissing her.
Whew.
Wow.
People are nuts.
Crazy.
They were barbarians.
They were basically just less than a hundred years removed from riding fucking
horses around.
What did you expect?
You know,
what did anybody expect from those fucking monkeys?
They were apes.
Remember when Barbara Walters got Sean Connery to talk about smacking my man?
Yeah.
Yeah,
he said it.
And it's really like it.
They like play that Chamie cause it's brilliant.
I mean it's,
it's incredible the way,
I mean,
he is just got this no nonsense approach to the pim pan.
And Barbara Walters tried to like check him on it and,
and he just fucking owned up to it and,
and really fucked her up man,
because he kind of let her know that if she got a little crazy you might smack
her.
She got scared.
There was a,
there was something to it,
man.
There was something behind it.
It was this thing,
just slap a woman now.
And then as I remember you said you don't do it with a clenched fist.
It's better to do it with an open hand because she's looking away and then she
turns towards him.
Yeah,
I remember that.
I really love that.
I haven't changed my opinion.
You have it.
No other can you think it's good to slap a woman?
No,
I don't think it's good.
It's bad.
I don't think it's that bad.
I think that it depends entirely on the circumstances and if it marriage it.
Yeah.
Well,
if you have tried everything else and women are pretty good at it,
they can't leave it alone.
They don't want to have the last word.
Then you give them the laugh,
last word,
but they're not happy with the last,
they want to share it again and,
and get into really provocative situation.
Then
I think you're absolutely right.
And what would
cause he can didn't dizzy.
Elaborate any further than that?
I don't,
I don't think so.
I think he just leaves it that,
but still,
man,
Sean Connery gets away with that cause he's handsome and he's got that cool
accent.
But imagine somebody else saying that.
Imagine law.
Yeah,
it's just bad.
I mean ultimately Sean Connery is just hitting women like from an old school
era.
So it's kind of funny to hear them.
Yeah.
That's why because of like Jude law,
I don't know what I'm saying.
Jude law again,
but he has a proper accent is a handsome guy.
If he wound up saying that an interview,
it would ruin his career.
Absolutely ruined his career.
Like who's a,
um,
a famous movie star today,
who's like a good example.
Like Ryan Reynolds,
I guess at the handsome guy.
I'm not sure that it is one of those.
Ryan Ryan,
Ryan Crest.
Imagine if Ryan Seacrest said that they would know he's gay.
People would know.
They're like,
I know what you're doing right now.
I don't think so.
No,
I don't think he's gay.
I think he's a workaholic.
Probably doesn't have time for sex.
Okay,
this guy,
that's why I'm Reynolds.
This handsome bastard.
If he said that,
if Ryan Reynolds said that sometimes you need to smack a woman,
Holy Shit with the backlash,
be extraordinary.
salon.com would dedicate months and months of of front page articles,
but what about all the sites defending him?
None.
There'll be a few of those fucking men's rights.
Sean Connery,
Fan Clubs,
few of those embarrassing men's rights sites where they did the right things
like,
okay,
come on you.
Why is he I went too far.
You fucks.
You ruined the whole argument.
The whole argument is divorced laws.
The whole argument,
the whole argument is how many guys get fucked over financial weird salon.com
started attacking patent Oswald.
You know,
it's not salon.com okay.
It's a writer.
A writer decided that they were going to pick a hot button topic that didn't
necessarily jive or make sense,
but they felt like because Patton Oswald was making fun of someone else's racism
by showing like this essentially very similar to a bear is getting in trouble
for except Patton.
Oswald is a fucking like obvious comedian and Avi and known as a pretty
sensitive guy.
Like the idea that he would say something racist just for the joke,
like he was,
they knew what he was doing and they decided to go for it anyway and that's when
he attacked them and he should have,
he should have their gross.
Like there's something about their,
uh,
their articles too.
If you go to salon.com one of the things is almost every article starts with a
question,
you know,
is,
is this the time to reconsider the,
the argument of WHO's funny or men or women question mark is this,
you know,
this is,
is this,
what's wrong with the right question mark?
You know,
like this,
it's,
it's weird there.
They're like opinion pieces that represent this article.
It just is like,
it's,
it's amazing.
This guess,
guess what?
Chicken Butt does.
Anti Vegan shaming.
Beginning preschool.
Is that they're a salon articles.
Yeah.
Hold on.
Mr. Show patriarchal hedge among and sketch show titles.
That's the man from Nantucket anti transgender subutex and classic Lillard.
So true.
It's so true.
Our knock knock jokes not inclusive to the homeless salon articles.
You dummies.
You fucked with the wrong guy.
Yeah you did.
He lit him up.
It's,
he's right man.
I mean I,
I get angry sometimes.
Like the other day they were comparing a Tina Fey too to Louis C K and like it's
a,
the the age old argument.
Who's funny or men or women.
Fuck you.
Here's what's funny.
You're funny people.
It's not men or women like Stop Amy Schumer's Hilarious Louis CK slayers and
Tina Fey by the way is in even a stand up or,
okay.
She's an actress.
She's funny.
Sure.
She's funny on shows.
She's funny and in movies,
but she's not Louis Ck.
Louie CK writes his own shit,
performed his own shit.
It's all his opinions on the world to say that,
that there's some sort of a debate who's funnier.
Her or him is completely distorting what the art form is in the first place.
It's completely distorting it.
Like you're just looking for a fucking salacious article title.
That's all you're doing.
I used to think,
I thought,
I thought they were like,
it seems like they were much more respected and now they've gone down this
spiral where everyone's just rolling their eyes at it.
They'll run out of shit to talk about what you,
you know?
I mean,
it's just ridiculous.
It gets to a certain,
it gets a certain time when you're covering the same stories over and over and
over and over and over and over.
This cancel Cole bear,
cancel cold beer.
One fucking joke has married like seven or eight headlines for articles from
them like in the debate and why he needs to make it right.
Make it right.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Like,
what are you talking about?
Make up a joke,
right?
Mean,
what was his joke?
I mean,
it was so fun.
Now,
first of all,
he's a character.
He's a right wing,
ridiculous character that says dumb shit,
tongue in cheek every fucking step of the way it was it offensive to which Asian
people I'll,
I'll,
I'll pull it up right now so we could see what the fuck and cold bear
controversy.
I'll,
I'll pull it up,
but people are asking like hash tagging,
hashtagging,
cancel co bear because of a fucking joke.
Okay,
here's the,
uh,
and he's apparently responded to it,
but let's find out what,
how many you,
how many people would respond to that Hashtag?
Oh,
I don't know,
but they were all gross.
I don't know how many people wandering,
how big,
if it's an actual big movement,
is it,
you can scan through it and it's not just cancel called bear.
There's like,
it's just like that.
It's like a place where all the outrage people have gone to express their
outrage.
They're pissed about anything,
and they'll just Hashtag [inaudible] has a copy page right now.
Here's,
here's what they said.
Okay.
It all began Thursday evening when the cold Baer reports Twitter account,
by the way,
which wasn't even him.
It wasn't even him that wrote that with some of that handles,
that Kobe Colbert account.
It's not,
it's not Steven Cole Bear quoted a joke from a segment on Wednesday's episode.
So they quoted a joke from a segment.
So they took it out of context and that's where the outrage came.
Quoted a joke from a segment that a aired that mocked Washington Redskins owner
Dan Schneider for setting up a charity to aid native Americans in lieu of
changing the team's name,
the original bid Colbert Bear said he was inspired by Schneider to start his own
charity called the Ching Chong Ding Dong Foundation for sensitivity to orientals
or whatever.
That's in response to a guy who runs a team called the Washington Redskins,
which is an anti native American slur making a charity for,
for for native Americans without changing the name.
Like it's the whole context to that joke.
I mean he's not saying that there should be a Ching Chong Ding Dong Foundation.
He's mocking the racism of a guy who's team is called a racist name.
Alright.
Donating without changing the name.
I mean it's so obvious,
but salon has had like seven fucking articles about it.
Some supportive,
but some that say he needs to make it right.
Maybe you just cannot put that string of words together in any content ever.
But I mean the Chung,
whatever he said,
I think that's exactly what they're saying.
You can't say change.
You can't say that.
That's the n word.
It's hilarious.
I mean to to to,
to try to censor content content that much that you're taking tanks completely
out of context.
Completely out of the meaning.
But context is the reason why language exists in the first place.
It's everything to be able to expand past really simple things like eat fuck
shit.
You need context to ha to have a goddamn language and communicate each other.
We have to recognize subtleties.
Yeah,
and when you pretend they don't exist,
that's when you get assholes sanctimonious fuck heads who get crazy about jokes.
That's when you get people dedicated days and days of their life to something
that fucking that Tracy Morgan says about stabbing his gay son.
They're crazy.
Everything is taken completely out of context and everything is something that
warrants cancellation.
You need to be shamed.
You need to be removed.
This is over sensitive fucking moron.
It's weird how what you're expressing right now is you're offended.
They offend you.
That's what's interesting is it's like they,
what they are doing is so much more offensive than the thing they are offended
by.
Yes.
The way they're expressing themselves is so vile and disgusting that it makes
whatever Tracy Morgan said or Patton Oswald said or cold bear say,
just seem like seems so tiny compared to what they are,
which is they're like embryonic fascists.
If you gave them power and they grew out of control,
if that,
whoever's like running the show at Salon,
Matt,
whoever's running the cancel cold bear and somehow they took power.
Imagine what kind of world
be living God if you,
they could decide what gets on these comedy shows.
The satire shows what you can and can't get away with.
How many transgenders need to be represented?
How many fucking gay people need to be as representative?
How many fucking straight white males need to be made fun of along with straight
white females.
I mean,
how's it going to be a,
a chart where everything's graft and made sure it's completely even across the
board.
Let's not life,
man.
Maybe they'll find something new to be pissed off about because that's really
what they love is being pissed off about stuff.
Oh,
they'd where they'd realize that they lost their love,
which is the problem.
It's when you say VA,
it's writers,
it's writers that they're attracting.
It's not necessarily logical people.
It's not necessarily like representative of the organization itself or
individual writers who produce something and then somebody greenlights set.
But at a certain point in time,
you're doing more harm than good because you're so easy to mock.
Or if you're like super left wing when you get that far out on a fucking limb
and you want to cancel Koga Era Kobe or about,
uh,
a really obvious joke like that,
you're fucking up everything cause you're,
you're making yourself look unbelievably silly,
right?
Like,
I know you feel right and I know the,
the,
you have this righteous indignation behind what you're doing and you feel like
the people need to know.
You need to realize the harm that your word say.
You need to realize that there's humor.
Okay.
And humor.
People get hurt.
Oh,
hiding.
You're a bigot.
Hiding behind the mask of a comedian.
People get hurt.
People get hurt from jokes.
And guess what?
If you get hurt from jokes,
you're supposed to get hurt from those jokes.
If you can't make fun of something about yourself,
that means you haven't acknowledged that something about yourself that may or
may not be hilarious.
And there's a big difference between someone saying something unbelievably cruel
and evil and someone's saying something where they're poking at you and
laughing.
And obviously he was doing that.
Obviously he was poking at the Washington Redskins guy and laughing and to deny
that it's just,
it fucks up the whole argument.
If it clouds the water was,
yeah.
It's strange
to see salon.com in some way,
like converging with Nancy grace in some way,
right?
Yeah.
Like they're meeting somehow.
Salon is like put itself in this terror.
Whoever the writers are has put themselves in that awful position where it's
like,
Oh shit,
I'm Nancy.
Grace and I are were like singing the same song and it's not all that.
There's a lot of great articles on there.
I still go there because they have a lot of great articles.
It's just sometimes they just go out along.
That's why you need a good editor man,
because you let a few writers fucking throw stuff out there and you do serious
damage to your website or magazine.
Like you can really fuck your shit up where you could develop a reputation.
You develop a bad reputation,
like a reputation for being ridiculous.
Oswald is attacking you,
is it for fun and people are looking forward to it and it rings true.
That's the problem is raining is true.
What he's saying.
Yeah.
You read those titles.
They're all,
I mean those are great mock salon.com titles.
They're great,
you know,
but look,
if you go to [inaudible],
I get an email from them every day and there's some great things like the,
the thing with John Stewart mocking CNN for its continued coverage,
they've got that they've got,
um,
an interesting thing on Chris Christie like the governor's talking about,
I'll bet I'll bet at all,
you know,
not all about it all,
but a friend of mine hated vice for a while and he's like Fuck Damn magazine.
Cause because one article that he was offended by that came up five years ago,
but I mean yeah,
you can't blame the whole organization because one thing fucked up.
Right.
Well there is,
there's definitely been some articles that I didn't like that vice did and I
loved those guys.
I saw one the other day that made me laugh that the liquid lap dance diapers,
what?
Yeah,
they have these diapers that people can wear and you fill it with Lube and you
go get your lap dance.
You just in your pants [inaudible] shit.
My friend,
one of the,
one of the are,
you know the whoever wrote it like warm and went to a strip club.
Now that that's where it is.
I wore a spend x diaper,
just strip clubs so I could come while receiving a lap dance.
That is hilarious.
Great article.
Oh I had a friend.
That's the kind of journalism I want.
That's a smart way of doing it too.
I had a friend who did it that,
wait a minute,
that's a gay strip club back up.
But they're marketed club.
Their market.
I think the writer just happened to be gay.
Yeah,
we've got a problem here.
This is a very different kind of lap dance they're receiving.
I didn't know that.
Totally different thing.
Gay Strip clubs.
Well now you know I have a friend who used to,
he used to shave his cock and balls and he used to take those nylon jogging
pants and he would run sandpaper on him until like you can like hold it up to
the light and see how many fingers you had up and then he would lube up his cock
and balls.
I'll shave down and he would put the really super thin,
like almost transparent jogging pants on,
put a long shirt over it and go to a strip club and get lap dances and he would
call it shooting.
I'd go shooting and one time we fucked up.
I guess he put too much lube on and the girls sat on him.
I was like,
what the fuck?
He's like,
oh sorry.
And he just gave her money.
He ran.
He said I was so embarrassed I ran out of there.
He said,
but before he had been getting away with it like girls had gotten,
they were like okay.
They'd climbed on it and made him come in his pants and he said it was amazing.
It was like a legal way to get hand job.
It's just thinking about like the lead up to that.
It's like how many times do you have to push down the thought I've gone insane.
Maybe he,
he invented those diapers cause that's a good,
I think someone,
I think he may have,
he was an entrepreneur.
I know cause there's already a market for it.
Yeah.
Maybe it's possible the diaper is a good move.
It's better,
it's more contained.
But you know,
but if your slot,
if you,
you know,
you're at home,
you're like,
you know what,
I'm going to slide on my lubed up.
Diapers.
You go get a lap dance.
It's like you gotta stop for a second was like you got to think cause like if I
was doing that I would add the alarm bells would be going up.
Like you've lost it man.
This is it.
You start wearing them to every everywhere cause you always wearing a lube
deputize cause you would,
you'd start liking it.
You start liking the weirds feel as I lube healthier thing.
No more girlfriends.
We'd be the only way you can come,
it'd be in the middle of having sex with like do you mind if I put the to down?
You're woman would be like,
what the fuck man.
Really you want to not have sex so you can put a diaper on.
There's guys that get so into jerking off if they can't come any other way.
Yeah,
I've about to come jerking off
man.
It's bad.
We've got a problem here and the problem is that that that hand jobs are illegal
at massage parlor.
So let's face it,
if guys have gotten to the point where they got to put on lubed up diapers,
do you go to feel a human touch to feel like an orgasm and by another person?
We've got to look at our laws.
You've got to like look at it.
This is repression managed,
gotten to the,
it's like when the pigs go crazy in the cages and chew their feet off man.
Yes,
some ancient fucking puritan bullshit because the idea that someone should be
able to do something completely free and it's absolutely legal encouraged and
it's a foundation of our advertising.
Selling sex is like almost everything we sell.
We sell it with sex.
How many cars have to have a woman's fantastic legs draped over the hood?
How many times have you,
you know,
watch some sort of commercialism hot woman promoting something?
What's going on there?
There's sat there saying you want sex,
you can get sex for free.
But as soon as you give someone money for sex,
that's against the law.
And everyone can be locked in a cage for something that doesn't hurt anybody.
It's completely legal.
If it's free or if there's a camera involved filming it.
That's true too.
Yeah,
you can get all fucked up part.
I think you have to get permits though.
Now.
I think they have permits you perhaps to get a permit,
you probably have some sort of permit.
Maybe not for the Internet.
Well I don't know.
I'm talking out of my ass.
But the bottom line is it's fucking sex.
It's not like beating someone up.
Imagine if you like had really poor people and you pay them to just,
you could beat the fuck out of them and they couldn't fight back.
Yeah.
You just,
I just want to pick the fuck out of somebody,
man.
I can't beat the fuck out anybody because it's so
you go to some warehouse and they give you some poor immigrant that could barely
feed himself and he just beat the shit out of him and the doctor comes in and
stops it before the guy dies.
And then he put this guy like in the hospital,
his face all fucked up.
But you give them like five grand and it ain't a couple of weeks he's going to
be healed up and that five grand is going to come in handy and now he's going to
pay for his green card and be able to get over this.
That's a possibility,
man.
That's a fucking real possibility that someone could engineer something like
that.
Like if,
if what?
Well if someone just decides,
someone just decides like,
Hey man,
you know,
I know there's a lot of people that would love to beat the fuck out of like,
but it won't be your martial arts skills and the guy can't hit back.
You just get that someone's not attack called bear does on the weekends he takes
the hits.
Don't fight club instead of putting yourself at risk,
it's just beat up club.
That's fucked up.
Yeah,
that's exactly man.
That's like a sick fucked up thing.
But like when you get a massage,
it does kind of seem like a hand job is like a natural conclusion to a massage
there.
Rubbing your feet.
They were rubbing your feet,
your body relaxed starts doing your toes.
It's almost sexual.
The squeezing your ass.
That's a big one.
They're always rubbing your ass.
It's a Roger Anas.
[inaudible] remember that shit that happened with a supposedly after or
Travolta?
Yes,
he got banned from a hotel because he would always try to get the Missoula to
arch his back up in the air and she's like his ass up in their face.
I don't know if that's real.
I don't know if it's really there.
It's funny story though.
Hilarious story and probably not real massager.
Volta loves Scientology.
Massages feel good everywhere your head.
It feels good a year.
Head massage.
You know they've rubbed your head sometimes.
That hardware your fingers.
It feels great.
Yeah.
Why can't they rub your Dick?
That's all he knows.
The danger zone.
Ah,
way too dangerous.
Can't touch it.
Pull that fucking towel open.
What have we done?
And you have to comes.
We go to jail.
I wonder what percentage of massage massage men have boners when they're getting
massaged.
80 because I don't think I can.
I don't get massages cause I'm worried that I'm going to feel awkward the whole
time.
Just like worried that I have a boner.
What are you communist?
Don't get you get jerked off.
He needed to talk to Brian Redman.
They'll hook you up with rub maps.
He knows.
He knows where to go.
It's gone beyond.
I've heard about that.
Brian has gone beyond.
Yeah.
Brian knows like some pretty dark,
dark place and he's the guru when it comes to find spots where you can get your
dick sucked.
It's illegal.
It's so stupid that it's illegal.
It's legal to have sex.
It's legal.
If you went outside right now,
walked out this door,
went to the door next door,
but went to the next office building and said,
uh,
hey,
who wants to fuck?
And some girl goes,
I'm off work and this is my office.
Let's fuck.
That's totally legal.
You go in there,
shut that door,
lock it,
and no one can stop you.
But if you walked in and said,
Hey,
uh,
I'm willing to give someone $1,000 if they fuck me.
And some girls like I could use $1,000 but I don't want to go to jail.
Shit.
Okay,
let's do it.
But shut up,
get in here and then the cops break down to earth.
People are fucking for money.
Bang.
Get on the floor.
Did you exchange cash?
You did.
You're both going to a fucking cage.
They could put you in a cage.
Yeah,
but if I went over there and said that,
who wants to fuck?
They'll probably be cops involved anyway if I just,
you never know what if you look like Ryan Reynolds,
if you look like Ryan,
that Ryan Reynolds cat and you walked into an office building and just said who
wants to fuck?
And maybe if you walked up to like one specific girl,
like maybe this is one everybody has.
This is one girl at almost every office building.
If there's an office building and has 10 floors,
there's one super slot in there.
There's one.
You just got to find her.
I mean she's,
she might be totally undercover,
just a normal looking secretary.
But she's got that fucking little hint of crazy in her eyes.
And if Ryan Reynolds walked in looking like that with his shirt open for some
reason and said he wants to fuck that girl would be there.
She'd be there and she'd be ready to throw it down.
We have to film this hidden camera show.
Just send me into an office building.
Oh my God.
You going to wants to fuck you get shot.
It's pieces of security.
It's easy to get a gun.
It's too easy to get a gun in La.
You don't want to do that.
How many infinite universes would happen,
Gatlin,
until I did get laid,
how many office buildings?
Not even what I would do like 400 buildings until finally you get laid every
time eventually,
but just take rise.
I just got to get good at this cell.
That selling Dj Doug Pounds supports rape culture live on [inaudible] dot com
[inaudible] dot com would just dedicate like to your show.
This show supports rape culture because it makes women,
I said it's wants to fuck.
Yeah,
because you make women think that it's okay for some threatening man to just
show up at the workplace and started threatening with there's penis.
He wants to use his penis.
He's letting everyone know.
We don't want to know that.
You want to use your penis attention,
attention.
I want to use my penis in this office.
It's Saturday.
Went interested,
but it is that how that could really almost be a show.
It'd be pretty hilarious.
Yeah.
Sin Dad to the zoo.
It's hilarious.
It's sad.
That could be a show.
If you have good show,
just dug walking into spots and trying to fuck,
can we call the show hilarious and sad.
Some people would beat your ass brochures and every now and then just get laid.
We'd have to film the whole season before anybody knew about it.
Finally to you get that one.
Yes.
It'd be like an Ali g thing.
I don't think you'd get,
I think you get many yeses.
I think you'd be amazed.
I think if you did just took a chance,
I think is a lot of people out there,
men and women,
you probably get a lot of men.
No,
fuck.
You have to do both.
Yeah.
You got to do both.
This show to be good at Princeton,
a wide net.
It's whoever says yes.
That's the other part of the show is the first person to say,
yes,
that's it.
You've got to be with it.
Doesn't matter.
I want to say game show.
Once they say yes,
I'm like,
you win $1 million.
Yeah.
You gotta you got a B.
Maybe that's the move.
We've got to re re reward.
Slutty.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's it.
If a girl says
the sex with her shit,
nevermind.
No,
no,
no.
It's a reward.
She wants a reward.
She won for being the biggest whore.
Now we're slut shaming will never go away.
We fucked up again.
I'm so sorry.
I do you know why that slut upping given her money.
Here we go.
I'm going to say something very unpopular.
I don't like the word slut.
Yeah,
I don't like it either.
Well,
it implies that there's something wrong with a woman having sex.
I think it's a fucked up word.
I think it's,
yeah,
it's,
it's weird.
That is a word I just like,
it's fun to use though.
It's funny you call them.
There's nothing wrong with being a promiscuous woman at all.
No.
Just like,
there's nothing wrong with being a promiscuous man.
There was a,
do you remember?
Let's,
let's just call her,
um,
uh,
waitress number one.
Do you remember,
which is number one from the comedy store from Boston.
She would always tell stories about banging all these different guys.
She would,
she was hilarious and she would tell stories about going out and banging all
these guys and almost always black eyes and she would just go and,
and,
and not almost always,
well,
it was one,
it was one joke.
I go,
when's the last time you fucked a black guy?
She was like,
forever.
Yos like seventh grade.
Yeah.
Right.
But she would tell us,
and we were all friends.
So it was,
it was fun.
It was like a guy talking about banging chicks,
but it didn't seem nearly as gross.
It was actually more humor filled because she was so free about it and it
wasn't,
I mean,
she was kind of bragging about it,
but it didn't hurt our feelings as men that she's out there fucking men and hurt
my feelings.
She was hot and I could never hook out.
And I remember,
I remember when she's wearing a pair of like really nice jeans and she told me,
I fucked the guy for these jeans.
I,
that's so funny.
And yeah,
I mean you wouldn't even if you would use the word slut,
you didn't meet it in a bad way with her.
You know,
I think the idea that a woman being promiscuous as any different than a man
being promiscuous,
it's so stupid,
so stupid and it's just a shit.
It terrifies.
It just terrifies guys who want to be in control to imagine that a woman can do
that without having to feel guilty about it.
That's what it does.
That's exactly what it is.
It's men who are worried about losing control over the woman that he loves body
or the idea that even before you guys hooked up that she had multiple sex
partners that will shame him.
He's walking around holding her hand and knowing that these guys all saw her
naked and had sex with her,
which is,
I mean that's just,
yeah,
it does happen.
I mean that is the course.
What happens?
Of course it's a test.
The Universe is testing.
Are you a bitch?
Okay.
If you freak out about some guy who fucked your girlfriend before you ever even
met her,
what's Europe?
Bitch cause only bitches claim to the past.
Especially somebody else's past.
What's wrong with you man?
You're freaking out about she,
well I was going through this,
this thing in college and one time I tried
a threesome.
Kicked the fuck Outta here.
Yeah.
It was these two guys and it was really fun and I wanted to do it again,
but God,
I don't want,
then they fight over you and one guy doesn't like it when you're having sex with
the other guy and it was just too much.
That's hilarious.
If you have that conversation with a chick you're dating,
it's kind of revealing.
It's cool.
Cool.
But for some guys like fucking whore,
you let those guts come you with this guy,
fuck your mouth with call your ass.
You let them fuck your ass too.
No big deal.
Yeah.
It's not like,
it's only like you're going to get married,
be the mother of my children.
It's weird because maybe we,
I would be saying the exact same thing but with a different tone in my voice.
Did you learn,
did they fuck your ass?
Oh Wow.
Really?
Oh,
let you do it.
Did you get off on it?
Yeah.
How Fun has it as it did that?
Was that like,
yeah.
Yeah man.
I,
I um,
yeah,
that's a,
that's a really sad thing.
I just feel bad because I think it's like,
I mean imagine if there was a negative connotation associated with guys having
sex a lot.
Imagine if your whole life was defined not just by like your sex drive,
but also by the sense of guilt tied in with it where you had to be.
You'll have like a guy I can have sex as much as he wants with pretty much zero
guilt.
But uh,
if,
if a woman does that,
there's this sense of like,
you,
you're losing the value almost as though you're like,
you know,
like,
like you're some kind of like,
I don't know,
you're something that's like gradually losing its essence and it's such bullshit
and so horrible to,
to,
to think that that you have to deal with that guilt.
That's something women have to deal with in.
It sucks man.
Their whole life is spent with this like undercurrent of guilt and when,
when they're with the guy,
even if they don't think it,
they've been so conditioned by like,
what is it like,
you know,
like virgin is like the cult of the verge and the idea that there is power in a
virgin or taking a girl's virginity or the untainted flower,
that bull shit still like every time you're like,
every time you're having sex,
you've been conditioned in some way so that it can,
you feel a little darker than you need to.
I'm sure many w I'm sure a lot of people have overcome that guilt,
but it's a guilt that guys don't have to deal with.
Right.
It's a,
yeah.
You don't have to go to therapy to be yourself,
right.
To satisfy your desires.
Yeah.
It's,
I read it,
I saw a picture on Twitter where,
uh,
it was like,
there was two pictures.
One was a woman asking and one was an ancient Asian guy,
an old Asian guy,
wise zen master replying like,
why is it when a man has sex with many women?
He's a stud.
But if a woman does it,
she's a slut.
And he said,
because,
uh,
a key that,
can open only open up,
oh,
a key that can open up many locks is a master key.
But a lock that works with any key is just a shitty lock.
That zen master sounds like a dick.
He just kind of an asshole.
He's a,
he's a slut chamber.
Fucking slut shaming.
Hey look,
I'm all for it.
salon.com I write an article about select shame and being bad.
You know what,
I think,
man,
I think what they're doing is they're responding to the injustices of the world
that are absolutely real.
They're just doing it in a way that I don't agree with.
And I think that what would be awesome is if these,
these things didn't exist at all.
If real sexism,
like real sexes,
we judge someone solely on the basis of their gender,
not their personality and their gender,
which automatically defaults to gender.
If you have someone that has a shitty personality,
even if they're productive and in the job,
like you don't like their gender,
like if they're a woman,
if you have an issue with a woman at work,
you can become a woman hater.
Just because by virtue of you having this argument with that one person,
I think until like that is resolved in our culture with like whether it's racism
or whether it's homophobia,
whether it's sexism,
you're going to have to deal with backlash even from jokes because people are
going to automatically want you to stop even joking about things.
Because if you have even those thoughts in your head or even express those
words,
you're hurting people,
but
you just can't be shrill man.
If you're going to fight the wharf,
don't be shy.
You know like don't,
if you do,
there is some merit and empathy.
If you're going to like go into a battle.
So wrong way of handling.
Yes.
Yeah,
use the right strategy because otherwise you end up doing the exact opposite of
what you intended,
which is that you come off looking like a moron and the issue itself begins to
seem even more relevant.
It does seem more relevant,
especially when you're not using humor and you're talking about humor.
Like you're discussing something in the context,
like as if it was said in court as an affidavit.
You know,
you're talking about it as if it's policy.
You're talking about it as if it's a statement like this is what I believe.
Let me sign there.
I've thought this through.
I've printed it out.
These are my views on the matter.
No,
you're no,
you're,
you're manipulating the context in which is even described.
Yeah.
Fucking dummies.
Dumb dumbs.
See you shit to get on to say dummy it pissing up the water.
I speak in a pissing off the water.
So how did you get involved with a Tim and Eric and how long you've been doing
it for?
Uh,
about nine years ago I,
I moved out to la 10 years ago and then nine years ago I answered a craigslist
ad.
I wanted to work on a funny TV show and I answered one craigslist ad said funny
TV show needs an intern.
That was them.
That's it.
Funny TV show needs an answer like comedy show.
And it turned out to be this cartoon that used to do called Tom goes to the
mayor.
Time goes to the Tom,
Tom goes to the mayor.
What was that on?
That was on adult swim too.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
So we did that show,
I think three seasons of that.
Um,
and then they started their sketch show,
Tim and Eric.
Awesome show,
great job.
And I just been working with those guys for a long time.
And you started out as an intern and then became a video editor?
Yeah.
After just a few months I already like had a bunch of experience and I brought,
I just,
they're kind of understaffed.
I just brought up my laptop and I just was like,
you guys need help.
I can help doing Photoshop stuff or whatever and let do a job.
Did you go to school for video editing?
I went to film school in Chicago,
Columbia College and I did do editing their,
I guess.
Oh that's cool.
So that's a great fucking Hollywood success story.
You applied for an ad,
showed up at a show that needed work added your influence actually helped it and
launched you it.
Yeah,
it was a great,
uh,
things kind of lined up.
Timing was perfect on that.
Well those are great guys to work with too because of their choices are so
bizarre,
you know?
But their choices are so unique that you kind of like,
you get established like really early,
not to take that cliche path,
whereas if you got like a gig that paid like really well but you had to do like
my three sons are,
what does that,
the two and a half men,
whatever the fuck.
Right.
If you had to do something like that cookie cutter.
Well it really,
it,
it eats on you.
It eats.
That's what I had been going on when I lived in Chicago.
I was editing like commercial,
not commercials,
but like just like stuff for like a pub publicity shit and stuff.
Like really just soul crushing boring stuff.
I think that's one of the reasons why Charlie Sheen went fucking crazy.
Like a lot of people think I'm an asshole for saying that.
What else is new?
Um,
but I was talking about mundane cause he's probably getting paid so much money
to do like the lamest.
Yes,
totally not challenging.
Not Exciting,
not thrilling.
No,
not creatively rewarding or right.
Whatever.
So he gets a little crazy and so to blow off steam,
what does he do?
He's just fucking getting cracked out and getting hookers and going nutty
Charlie Sheen cause it's two and a half men.
Um,
Duncan just got back from being,
I think that's party.
That's partly,
I'm one of the reasons why he flew off the handle.
I mean,
yeah,
he's obviously got addictive personalities,
but I think working on a show like that is so soul sucking.
I think if it was me,
I would say,
okay,
I have $100 million.
Like right.
I can just do stuff I'm interested in,
but maybe he just had no kind of creative angle on something.
We'll look at the difference between him then and him now in his anger
management show.
You fucking never hear about them anymore.
I mean,
he's not going crazy anymore when it seems to be a better show.
I keep hearing good things.
Eddie Bravo Lux and he thinks it's hilarious.
I've,
I haven't washed it,
but I hear it's funny.
And so he's doing this new show now that is like more creative,
really refreshing or whatever or maybe just got burnt out.
Maybe we did so much coke.
He's just got to stop.
Yeah.
He knew it was almost over.
Maybe watch his own interviews and went,
Whoa,
whoa.
What the fuck was I doing?
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Just how,
that's how I roll.
What,
uh,
he owns a piece of that too.
So he's making money even when Ashton Kutcher's on it.
Yeah.
I just don't understand.
Like for me personally,
I would,
I wouldn't take a job if I thought I'd be doing six months,
cause I just recently got an offer to do it.
Something that went for nine months,
but it was like,
it might be something that I kinda be bored with.
I'd rather take less money and do less jobs,
but just pick the ones that I really loved doing.
I don't think a lot of times you get involved in a sitcom,
you don't think it's going to be a piece of shit until you're actually working
on it.
I was on a sitcom.
I'm not talking about it.
A Sitcom or anything.
Sitcoms are tricky.
They're fucking tricky man.
I was on a sitcom that was a piece of shit and it started off really good.
Uh,
it was called hardball.
And these guys,
Jeff Martin and Kevin Curran who wrote for the Simpsons and they wrote from
married with children.
They were really good writers,
really funny guys and Fox didn't think that they can handle it,
so they took the show away from them and gave it to this hack from coach.
You know that show coach?
This guy,
I don't know what he did on coach,
but whatever he did,
he fucked up anything that was good.
He brutalized the script,
he brutalized the,
the work environment.
He just,
he alienated those guys from their own show and came in and rewrote everything
on his yacht,
went to his yacht and rewrote everything.
I mean it was diggity diggity dog shit.
It was one of the worst fucking changes from pilot to actual series ever.
No one was happy.
Everyone was like really,
really broken up about it and then they wound up firing him and then they gave
it back to the writers.
But it was too late.
The show,
isn't it?
Fucking four episode Tailspin.
We did it only wind up airing like five or six but I got to see that happen.
I got to see something that was really good or a bunch of dimwits came in and
threw in their 2 cents.
It just shit all over it.
That seems to happen a lot.
Where like the original creator gets like kicked off his own show.
Like you know John Crystalucci,
they guy who did ren and Stimpy.
Yeah,
he got that happened to him.
He like created this whole show.
He was like his thing,
his complete vision.
And then I think they fired him and like kept doing his show without the
creator.
Oh my God,
that's so crazy.
Harman Harman,
Dan Harmon and similar community.
Right.
They brought him back.
Yeah.
Well that's the only way you're going to get that show dummy like that.
The thing about your show,
and I'm not blowing smoke up your ass,
but your show is so obviously you,
it's so,
you have this funny little smile in every episode where
you're not the best actor in the world.
You're not trying to be,
but it's half of what's funny about it is that you're,
you know,
you're,
you're going through these incredibly ridiculous scenarios over and over and
over again and I could recognize that you're,
you know,
you're enjoying the actual piece while you're a part of it.
And it's really fun,
man.
It's cool if somebody came in fucking started adding to it,
you know,
especially some suit from coach,
they would just dick all over this shit.
What are you showing me right now is horrible.
I don't see why it's funny.
I would love to just keep making these little youtube shows then have someone
have that situation happen,
like where some network changes it and I dunno.
Well I think your show ruins it in some way could probably become so big because
it's so good that they can't do that.
I think it's totally possible.
I think I,
I'm not blowing smoke up your ass again.
I think your show is really fucking good and I think like letting all these
people know about it now you're going to get like more people downloading it and
letting more people know about it.
On Twitter.
It's just a matter of time.
It's the,
the,
the finding finding it is what's hard sometimes it's like there's so much good
shit out there now.
It's hard for people to find stuff.
So what is true when you have a podcast,
it's one of the cool things that you get to be,
you get to be like a guy who likes,
shows,
people some cool stuff that you found,
I guess to,
you know,
open the door for them.
So you're probably not going to need a network.
They'll just fuck it up.
They would never let you get away with that.
There might be a network that would let him,
there might be a network and adult swim maybe.
I mean they let Tim and Eric do their thing.
Yeah.
What kind of resistance did you guys have ever actually adult swim is,
is pretty cool.
Like that.
Yeah.
They kind of like Tim and Eric and a lot of freedom to obviously,
yeah,
I mean fucking show.
So crazy.
Yeah,
that shit was so fun to work on because I would do screwed up edits like chop
things up and like whatever,
like kind of make a joke out of it just to show them to so they could,
you know,
just almost to like surprise them thinking they're going to hate this but it'll
be funny to see them and then they'd be like do more of that,
you know,
they push,
push the weirdness and the network would be like that to like make it weirder,
which is like a great note to get.
I found out about you guys from Eddie Bravo,
Eddie Bravo.
I'm like,
I don't know if he got it on online or on.
Is it available online?
Like how could you,
there's a DVD available,
anything like that and Eric stuff.
Yeah.
I think@adultswim.com they have like a ton of episodes and,
but there's DVDs somewhere.
Yeah,
it must be.
I'm pretty sure I got DVDs because I remember him watching like a ton of them in
a row and having people over the house to watch him.
People look like,
what the fuck are you watching?
I'm like,
and they're like,
he's like,
you got to understand what they're doing.
You're don't understand what they're doing.
And like he would have some people and he would try to show it to them out of
context and they just totally,
they'll get really mad at it.
It's just not funny.
They get mad that people think it's funny.
Yeah.
That was,
Eddie got some of those reactions,
but he fucking loves that show.
God Damn.
He's always talking about that show.
It's just such a weird show.
What was the one where they play like,
I think it was,
was it Eric?
The played the guy that was in the,
um,
the,
uh,
there was a trailer park and he got pregnant.
Uh,
that was,
that was for funny or die.
That was the ticket.
It's called the Terrys.
Yeah,
the Terry.
That was intense.
Fucking crazy.
That was one of the craziest things I've ever seen.
Yeah.
It was so ridiculous and preposterous and a perfect example of just taking
something to this incredibly weird place that you never saw common.
Yeah,
it's great.
Terry's.
It's good one.
Yeah.
And where I'm does music videos now,
like really good music video.
If you've seen what like,
oh yeah,
you should see somebody.
These music videos.
Have you ever seen some of the music videos?
He does.
Yeah.
You would love bubble Ba.
Ah God.
You should watch bubble.
But man,
this pull that I did a music video with Eric.
I'm called back Bush.
Backpacker.
Bush.
Yeah.
Backpack or over back backpacker Bush.
When we were at this backpacker bar and he was talking about
the bushes there and we should make a song or a rap about it.
Like if you've been fast pack,
uh yeah.
Let's play that man.
I want to see that again.
Seen that in Hawaiian.
Crack me up.
Okay.
Put on backpacker Bush.
It's true,
man.
It's true though.
If you've been in the,
on the Appalachian trail and you're just hiking,
I'm sure you have a massive,
yeah.
Bush.
Is that what they were talking about?
Are they talking about bushes?
You'll see.
Okay.
Don't tell me.
Let's just watch it for folks at home.
Why is Doug Benson on their skip ad and the ad for what?
He has a show on that channel.
Oh,
getting Doug with high,
I think,
right?
Yeah.
Smell up here.
It's like a wait,
you got something else planned?
Oh,
you fucking SAP.
What is that
guy?
A lot of tabs going right now though.
What is that?
That was the adult swim.
Yeah.
This takes a little minute.
13 just once into the club here.
There's a giant fat black guy with gold chains on.
Just looks like a pretty creative and funky place.
It's got to be some trim.
You hear from me tonight?
I'm looking for strange.
I'm hunting for sleep.
I like to choose my songs.
I'm a condom.
Linkous to please my lovers with my sexy.
Nothing.
They always climax when I lift him like this.
I just won't stop until you come mocking.
Hit the G spy with my long hair.
You have to see,
man,
you have to see how preposterous.
He says we're missing so much of it and yeah,
we don't have to play the whole thing.
I just wanted to,
yeah,
let's not because otherwise it's just a bad rap.
It sounds like it.
Yeah.
It's like the context is that you've got this giant weird rapper in a backpacker
bars.
You're surrounded by hippies,
the opposite place.
Did he go to hook up with anyone?
Yeah.
It's pretty strange.
You got it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it does.
It pride.
A little button is another one that I recommend.
I would check that out.
Yeah.
This is not something you should listen to it.
You should definitely watch it.
You got to watch all these.
Yeah.
Well that's the beautiful thing about their show.
The show is,
you know the visually,
it's so bizarre.
There's so much weird shit out now because of that.
You know,
because sort of opens up the doors to this observed sort of style of comedy.
I think it's becoming more popular.
Right.
I like that.
Yeah.
I liked that.
The fact,
I like the fact that the inner,
like anyone can have their own thing and if it goes,
if it catches on,
it kind of catches on.
Yeah.
Like we were talking about,
um,
people that were on Twitter that are funny on Twitter,
it's very democratic,
right?
Yeah.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
All it needs is a,
what is this jammy?
Yeah.
Let's not play this while we're talking.
I won't know what the fuck you're doing.
Um,
I think it's,
uh,
it's,
it's beautiful because all it takes is like one person to find it.
They send it to someone else.
That person says,
and it virally spreads.
I mean,
so many things that are made by regular folks just virally spread that don't,
it doesn't even have to make sense.
Like there was,
there was some people that were not famous at all and they made some Christmas
rap about,
uh,
like doing something in their Christmas jammies.
It was like the,
the husband,
the wife and the kids.
It's kind of like fucking 30 million views or something like that.
And it was just totally homemade thing that they did.
And it's just people started sending to each other at work and then next thing
you know it's this gigantic,
huge fucking thing.
Just a freight train running over America,
spreading from email to email.
I did,
I did these videos.
Ever seen the Gi Joe,
a voiceover remix videos from now 10 years ago or so.
Good man.
Yeah.
My me and my friend made the first,
well it was like mate,
really my friend Eric fencers idea.
But what is it?
They went like a viral,
there are these little 32nd you know what you know about those were,
I knew about this before.
I knew you had done it doc.
Like I watch those when I was in,
probably like in my last year of college,
it's like late nineties we made them for you tube.
They re voiced over GI Joe commercials more like what their lips would kind of
be saying,
but just mixed in with just weird.
It's just we,
it's the same stuff that you do manage just the same wholesome up.
God,
I don't know.
I hope it translates.
No,
those are good to listen to because there's 30 seconds.
Okay.
All right.
What's smelled like best about,
yeah,
Joe Public Service announcements.
You're not my friend.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
well,
I'm just curious what you mean.
He said,
dude,
you're talking to you.
Well,
my friends are here.
Oh cool.
See you later.
Okay.
I get you.
Stop that you have,
but I did that boys.
Who's that weird dude?
You're talking to your brother?
Wow.
You'd have to see that.
That's another,
it's the cartoon,
the Gi Joe Cartoon with different voices over it.
Now.
I kind of remember it,
but we did those before youtube and we put them,
we made like a quick time of them.
You know,
back in the day you had to like watch a quick time.
What's more important before youtube or a BC?
That's the new,
let's hit reset on time.
Yeah.
Where we are.
We are in the year five
right now.
What year are we in Wendy's before youtube is the new BC.
I mean it's fine.
Like for historical reasons.
Yeah,
we got hit.
We sat on the clock.
If you really stop and think about it,
the,
the ability to distribute information like that in video form never existed
before like that again.
That's sort of a quick and easy to me really will have an impact.
It's similar to a messiah that is wild.
Youtube is the Messiah in a lot of ways.
While the Internet certainly is,
and a lot of ways,
you know,
I mean the,
if the Internet wasn't a real thing and you talked about it,
if you were all sitting around a campfire and you're like,
one day there will be a discovery and the discovery will be that we can
communicate our ideas,
not just through our mouth,
but through wireless transmissions that can be picked up on the other side of
the world.
Internet could work not just on one continent,
but on all cops get tied up in that camp.
They would go crazy.
They didn't get the flashlights out.
[inaudible] Donald Bruno guy on fire because he insisted that the universe was
infinite,
you know?
So imagine what the fuck they would do to you if you ever predicted the
Internet.
Oh my God.
Anything that anyone could say right now that they would get thrown in jail for
like about a scientific concept?
No,
no,
not done.
We're past that.
We're done.
Except if you're in like some shit hole that you know,
still wants to teach creation as I know what to throw you in jail because like
there's all these people that are freaking out because of what Neil Tyson said
on cosmos.
Wait,
they just don't want it there.
Their counterpoint is what they want.
Right.
They want it to also the creation.
His point of view too,
because he was saying pretty clearly,
you know,
we understand the creation is kind of ridiculous.
Like Biblical side of the universe is so tiny.
What were you saying?
What do I thought?
I read it in the Middle East.
They were gonna they atheism was being criminalized or something,
but I don't remember where I saw that in some parts of it.
Probably the CIA just trying to get us excited about going over there and
fucking things up.
You know,
like atheists.
Yeah.
I mean they're,
they're not even allowing atheist.
So then the liberals have to step in and go,
we have to protect the atheist,
you know,
in salon.com should we invade Syria since they're assaulting atheists,
should we now reconsider our invasion to protect atheism?
I don't think that would sell as hard as if they were like,
you know,
black and Christianity or something.
I think that propaganda should be like a crime of the highest order manipulation
like that.
If that was really true,
if someone actually really did do something like that in order to get people
excited about war and made up some bullshit about them attacking atheism in
order to get support on one side and that knowing that people were going to die
because of that,
that should be true.
Yes.
It should be treated as like more than capital murder cause it's murder of
possibly hundreds of thousands if not millions of people who knows.
Maybe cause you could cause with one engineered conflict it could cause a chain
reaction that would cause a nuclear war,
which maybe ruin the environment forever like that.
You should be treated like that.
But anyone who instigates war,
like we were so nonchalant about the idea that they were considering a false
flag attack on Iran,
a false flag attack that I ran engineered on America right before the end of the
Bush administration.
You guys wear that?
Yeah.
It was something.
Is it a known fact that,
I'm pretty sure I should probably Google it,
but Cheney,
let's,
let's look up Cheney planned false flag.
Cheney plan.
False flag.
I Ran Cheney.
I think it was pretty much established that they were considering it.
I heard he's a nice guy though.
He's just shit
I hear he's like,
he's,
he's like so cool.
Like well if you're ever having to get rid of a beer with him,
he's a great guy.
Yeah.
The media blackout on Cheney.
I ran false flag.
There's a guy,
um,
Google it.
Um,
Jamie cause it's only four minutes.
Who's a guy talking about it?
Um,
I really
article that you wrote that I found actually most interesting in the article
hasn't gotten that much attention.
But I want to get your take on this,
and this relates to a story or an incident that happened a couple of months ago
and many of you remember it.
It was in the straight of water moves.
There was an incident where an American carrier almost blew a couple of Iranian
speed boats out of the water and perhaps would have started,
uh,
the next war,
a war against the law,
and I'll hop potentially a world war three.
And it was a Verdad,
thankfully at the,
at the last second,
we later learned that there was really nothing to be terribly concerned about.
The incident was overblown and that there was a vice admiral in charge of the
fleet and the,
and the Strait of Hormuz who said basically there was,
there was no concern there that it was overblown.
But yeah,
the second part,
basically he is concerned,
but again,
we're blending.
It never threatened me.
He never threatened.
And you talk about this Jen vice admirals name is Kevin Cosgrove.
And,
and in your article you write nonetheless cost Crufts demeanor,
angered Cheney according to the former senior intelligence official.
But a lesson was learned in the incident.
The public had supported the idea of retaliation and it was even asking why the
US didn't do more.
The former officials said that a few weeks later,
a meeting took place in the vice president's office.
The subject was,
had to create a casus belli lie between Teflon and Washington.
He said,
what you're writing there is that Cheney there was meeting in the White House,
were chaining,
presided over looking to cook up the next war,
like a false war based on false intelligence.
Uh,
my oldest son is a lawyer and when I fell,
I send them this story before it was published,
that basically in a final form it just a day and he wrote back and he said,
you really very deleted this one,
but casus belli um,
how many persevere?
Anyway,
there was a meeting among the,
among the items among the items considered and rejected,
which is why I did New York who did not publish it on grounds that it wasn't
accepted.
One of the items was why not every,
there was a dozen ideas profit out of how to trigger,
or the one that interested me the most was,
why don't we bill,
we and our shipyard bill four or five,
I weighed boats that look like Iranian PT boats,
put Navy seals on them.
There's a lot of arms,
and the next time one of our boats goes to the Straits of Hormuz start to shoot
up my cost some lives and it was rejected because you can't have Americans
killing Americans.
But that,
that's the kind of,
that's the level of stuff we were talking about application,
but that was
holy fuck.
That was rejected.
But the idea that that could ever even be discussed,
and you're not talking about the 1960s either.
You're talking about the 2000 come on,
we're just spit balling here.
We'll just throw it out like,
hey,
the only way to really got to be free box a little bit.
How come you guys are all for fucking freedom with chokes?
We can't be free with foreign policy.
Yeah,
come on.
We got to be creative brainstorming,
throwing things around.
Man.
We're not committed to these things,
man.
We're fucking free spirits here and that's the kind of outside the box thinking
that got you in that position.
Dick.
He had a fucking fake heart for a while and you didn't even know it.
Pulse,
if that's not in the Bible,
you tell me what it is.
A dude who was running the military as a constant blood pumping straight
through.
You touch him.
He doesn't have a pulse.
He's dead.
There's even a real pump.
No,
no,
he's,
yeah,
real heart.
He had a heart transplant.
He got somebody else's heart.
I would've kept the fake one.
I just have a joke about it a lot in his heart.
That's what that operation was about.
I had a joke about how there was an extra secret service agent and the everybody
else was eating burgers that gave him Tofu and salad and it was like,
what the fuck?
And you're like,
jog more laps.
I don't want fucking,
you guys aren't jogging fucking jog more labs and they follow chain no matter
what with a a giant truck that had no markings on it.
Like what's with the truck?
Shut up and do more laps and then the moment Cheney dies,
they fucking tased this guy,
hold him down.
Got Him like a fish,
pull out his beautiful healthy Tofu,
written heart,
open Cheney up,
throw them in the back of the truck and stitch them together.
When you open up Cheney's chest cavity bats fly.
It's probably like that episode or that the scene in the movie,
the thing John Carpenter movie,
whereas chest opens up like a giant mouth and just fucking snaps your arms off.
It's its own mouth.
Do you remember that scene and that thing that to the thing guide where they
first found out that there was a fucking monster amongst them.
Great movie.
Oh,
it was great.
You know,
there's a really old thing.
It's really kind of interesting.
That's the one I'm talking about.
I don't like the new one.
No,
no,
no.
So there's three.
There's three,
yeah.
There's one from the 1950s I believe it's,
I think it's the fifties you're judge carpenter thing.
It's like a really legit scary movie that is.
Oh yeah,
the John Carpenter is great.
Hey man,
the new one's not bad either.
The new one is not bad.
The thing from another world,
it's called from 1951
it's based on the,
yeah,
that's the original story.
The original story is the same thing.
They're out in the cold.
It's fucking great because it's not just a movie.
It's also a time capsule like you.
You're watching like they didn't know shit about making movies back then.
Like the way they did it.
The,
here it is right here.
Look at this.
There's still figuring out how to scare people with film.
Same Font.
This is the spot where it was the first scene and these are the first people who
saw the thing.
This is a Tim and Eric Sketch.
Where did it come from?
Did I hit it?
I know it happened to coming up and making it and he's like,
oh,
why did you
smack him?
Just like a woman going through water in their face to both of them.
Just Tom didn't question.
That's not even the world's greatest scientific minds connoisseur.
Gentleman.
Do you realize what we found?
Uh,
being from another world,
it's different from us is one pole.
You can only communicate with
greenhouse.
I was working,
I couldn't see then.
Then a blast of cold air and I heard those screen.
Come here.
Get my car.
No,
this in front of you.
This will be in my Netflix queue.
Oh,
it's got to be,
man.
I'm telling you.
You just got to get super big to watch it.
I get the monster's coming.
I'm going to shoot it.
It's on fire.
So stupid planes cannot destroy the thing.
Oh my God.
No.
Our bullets killing
a story of modern science that challenges our imagination.
Okay.
It's awesome though.
Really the full movie.
I watched it on a plane.
I was trapped.
There was nowhere to go,
so I've watched it.
It was,
movies are always better on the plane.
A lot of times it was a,
it was available.
It was for,
I was flying to England and it was a long flight and they had like a pretty good
selection of movies that you could rent or you could watch rather.
And this was one of them.
I find joy,
the shit,
I haven't met him.
I was like in tears watching a Jennifer Aniston like Rom com.
It made you cry like laugh.
Cause I was on a plane.
No,
for some reason I was like connecting with the story and like watering up.
Like why,
what is it about the plane?
Is it the oxygen on a plane?
I loopy you drunk.
I should have wore my diaper.
I should've wore my lubricated diaper.
I watched too woody Allen movies on a plane.
I haven't watched woody Allen movies forever and I watched two of them on a
plane,
a bunch of blue jasmine on a plane aren't,
did I watch it in a hotel room?
But I watched,
um,
uh,
the other one,
I'm playing midnight in Paris.
I like that one.
It's a good fucking movie.
But I wouldn't never sat down and wash that if I wasn't trapped in a seat.
It was a good movie,
but it was interesting watching Owen Wilson play woody Allen.
Have you seen it?
Yeah,
I don't remember doing woody Allen's.
Oh that's we.
Um,
I guess I wasn't paying attention when I watched the home cause you not pay
attention to that.
I mean it's like so obvious what he's doing.
He's doing his version of Woody Allen.
I mean he is woody Allen.
Woody Allen's too old to do that character anymore.
Nobody wants to see him talk about being in love anymore.
So he has to have other people sort of play him like as avatars.
Owen Wilson is his essentially his Avatar in that movie.
It's a trippy movie.
It's a really trippy movie.
Hmm.
He's a weird case man.
Oh one no woody.
They both of them.
Yeah,
they're both long flight.
I was on,
I saw Barry Lyndon Kubrick film.
Oh yeah.
It's like four hours long,
but I was flying to New Zealand so I had like all this time to kill and I,
that's like never a film that would ever watch cause it's like four hours long.
But that's the one that they say that that's one of the ones that spine,
it's cool man.
Huh?
Cause they say that the,
so that's how I wanted to film candle light without using um,
regular lighting.
So we needed a special kind of camera to do it.
And they say that NASA developed this Special Lens to film candle light or
something.
And then that's the beginning of the conspiracy theory that he traded this lens
for.
Yeah.
He invented his own
on camera.
He,
I don't know the exact details,
but he like took a NASA camera and like put his own special lens on it.
Or Barry Lyndon was 75
no,
but it was the,
in the setting,
you know what I mean?
Like you wanted to shoot candle light.
Oh right.
But the movie,
the movie came after the moon landing.
Tell me guys,
I didn't write it,
I don't know.
16 between 69 and 72 where it was all the a moon missions.
We went to the moon.
Right.
We went to London in [inaudible] 78 most likely,
I would say 99% but it would be awesome if that 1% was true.
If they really faked it,
there'll be hilarious.
I'm still willing to hold that hope it'd be cooler if they fake data,
if they really went there for sure.
Faked it.
Really?
Yeah.
At this point in time,
because it's even more of an accomplishment to know that people who have been in
space,
we know that people definitely can go to space.
We know that people definitely can go to space stations.
That's all.
Those are huge accomplishments.
Going to the moon for sure is another huge accomplishment,
but faking that they went to the moon is a magnificent display of propaganda.
Yeah.
If they really did do that,
it would be incredible.
I was convinced for years that they fit,
man.
That's something like,
do you ever get that weird ache when you realize like you'll never get to stand
on the moon or like you'll never get to stand on Mars?
That feeling of,
I don't want to ever stand in those places.
Those places do suck.
Fuck.
Do you know how dare you would be amazing to,
oh,
I don't know.
I said,
how dare you about insulting Mars.
It will be cool though.
It will be so like,
or like when you read about Titan and how it's like oceans of methane.
Yeah.
You can't live on their son,
but it'd be cool.
I know,
I'm just saying you are a mortal
that like see what an ocean of methane look like.
They could make,
they could send a camera there.
I'll watch the footage.
They'll be,
did they still be happy with that?
They did send the camera.
Are they a yeah,
I think that's the move from now on.
I think it's send a drone to get deep in film the stuff until we get so
advanced.
I mean we have to get so fucking advanced that we can just go places like
instantaneously.
Then it will be exciting,
you know,
because like look,
traveling to another country used to be some insane thing that no one did when
they had sailboats.
I mean we can't even wrap our head around how distant Australia was 500 years
ago.
We can.
We can't.
It's not available to us.
The idea isn't even available that we didn't even know you were the average
person that lived here in America.
You have the concept of Australia was so alien to you,
but now it's a mean 20% of the people that you run into a bin Australia.
Right.
I mean,
what I mean of us,
at least if you're traveling around with Comedians,
it's probably even higher than that.
I know a lot of people that have been Australia,
I know people,
Jim Jefferies,
who was on the podcast the other day,
he fucking is from Australia.
You know what I mean?
It's normal week.
We can't even imagine what it's going to be like a thousand years from now and
you probably can go to a planet easily when you can go to space easily.
It probably will be like a thousand years of innovation because I think that the
difference between getting out into space and then getting back pretty quickly
and actually going somewhere and living like Battlestar Galactica type shit.
Yeah.
We're probably so fucking far from that.
We're so far from that,
that it's as far as the Internet is from people who are riding horses from the
Internet is before they invented the wheel.
Right.
I think the coolest invention would be teleporting.
Yeah.
If you could just like be in Hawaii right now,
right after this,
we'd walk outside and just snap and we're on Kauai.
Hawaii.
It'd be fucked if they invent teleporting.
That would be pretty dope.
That's probably ruined the world,
wouldn't it?
It was just too much tramp that we won't be trampling on the pretty places.
Just teleport to why?
Like if it was an app,
Hawaii just be filled with people.
Yeah.
Q Magine.
If you could just instantly go to Hawaii anytime you wanted.
The beautiful thing about Hawaii's,
it takes five hours to get there on a plane.
That's what's so awesome about it.
The quickest way to get there.
Yeah.
Five bucks an hour.
That's why it's so awesome.
Did you ever read that Stephen King Story?
The gr uh,
the jaunt?
No.
What is it?
Oh,
it's so good.
I think it's called the John.
Oh fuck.
It's so good,
man.
It's like they've invented teleportation.
It's somewhere in the future.
They have like airports for teleportation,
but the thing is they've got a nest of the ties you so that you're asleep when
you go through because if you're awake when you go through it feels like
infinity.
It feels like you're floating and blackness for infinity and people come out the
other side insane or like you know,
like they've lost their minds because it did the,
their,
their jibberish and that's probably how it will be because what would
teleportation be like disassembling you're Adams and then reassembling it
somewhere else or something?
Yeah,
yeah.
That's a good question.
I mean,
is it going to be like some star trek type shit in this story?
They say like it's a really quick story so you can barely see it could just read
it.
This is a little bit of a spoiler,
but you should just read it anyway.
But they want to know what happens inside the teleportation device because they
figure out that if a thing is awake when it comes through the other end,
it dies.
So they get someone on death row and they tell us,
if you go through and tell us what happens in there,
we're going to like,
let you off the hook.
Your sentence will be forgotten.
You'll be forgiven.
Guy Gum comes out the other side.
He's like fucked up and he says
it's a long time in there and then he dies.
Well,
did you hear about that with recent idea that they'd come up with some sort of a
chemical treatment they would give to someone that would allow them to live a
thousand years in eight hours would be the equivalent of a thousand years in
eight hours.
What?
Yeah,
exactly.
Super strong weed.
Salvia.
I'm really slows down.
I don't know the logic.
Yeah.
Behind it.
I don't understand that.
I've tried to understand what they're,
what they're saying,
but the idea being that you would experience the equivalent of a thousand years
by yourself in eight hours,
that would suck because you can't like read.
Uh,
what would you do?
You're just like in a state of staring God that does.
That sounds like a great,
could be a horrifying experience.
Well,
not only that,
who's to say that you hear prisoners could serve a thousand year sentence in
eight hours.
Biotechnology could be used to make prisoners feel as if they were serving a
thousand year sentence.
Oh my God.
Well the problem is,
man,
then those people can really serve those thousand year sentences.
They could day with those people would fucking come out crazy.
Yeah.
He would come around and helping society with that thousand year sentence like
the Bradley manning situation.
They kept that guy.
Now girl,
um,
they kept him in a cell by himself for days,
days,
days became years,
years,
years.
Alright.
No contact with human beings.
Totally naked and cold and w and then just broke him just over time.
Just broke him,
broke them.
I mean the,
the,
the idea that you could go through years and years of solitary confinement naked
and be the same person you were when they brought you in there.
This is ridiculous.
There's a lot of people in solitary confinement.
I heard some story about it,
like an NPR or something.
Like they used to do it as like a special punishment.
Put you in there,
put you in the hole for a little bit,
but now it's like people are just permanently in solitary for like years or
something.
Why would it be only contact is like when they get the lunch guide sliding the
luncheon.
That's fucking crazy.
That's fucking completely crazy.
Like the idea that you can do that to a human being.
I mean if you want to do that to a human being,
you should be killing that person.
Yeah.
I would rather die than do that for the rest of your life.
The rest of your life by herself.
That's a weird kind of special torture.
Yeah,
you're just holding them here for some reason.
You're like,
we're just going to keep you on the edge of for as long as
we can.
We'll keep you alive.
But everything that you know,
everything that you have come to understand as being a human being is totally
taken away from you outside of the basics.
You can eat,
you can shit.
You can piss and sleep,
but that's it.
So
yeah,
it's a beautiful and pushups and burpees.
It's the idea.
The idea is unbelievably insane.
And there's nothing you can do about it.
That's just what they do and to try to change that.
Now,
I mean there's a,
there's a God damn momentous movement.
I mean the amount of people that have been put in solitary confinement,
the amount of time that's been devoted to this style of torture they can take
you and remove one of the most important aspects of being a human being,
human contact,
and then just break you,
break your mind.
How is that helping society by like torturing someone?
We fix that person.
Look at that.
There are 80,000 Americans currently held in solitary confinement.
What the fuck?
Well,
what's number three on that list?
Solitary confinement was developed as a humane alternative to what?
To shoot him in the face.
Head waterboarding.
They didn't even have water body,
but then that's some latest onboarding is an old technique.
Yeah.
How old is that?
They used,
there's reports of them doing it in a,
I think the the like the eight late 18 hundreds or world war one or something.
In this book I'm reading about about World War II pilots,
they're talking about somebody was torturing someone with waterboarding
techniques in kind of makes sense.
Philippines.
Wow.
It's been around solitary.
Scary shit man.
I mean,
if you really think that someone's that bad,
we shouldn't we remove them.
We should remove them from society.
Like remove them,
period.
And if you don't,
you gotta you gotta give them what it is to be human.
You got to let them interact with people.
If you don't,
I mean you're,
you're not just punishing them,
you're torturing them.
It's a constantly tornado drip.
It's not solving a problem.
It's making like more problems.
Right?
Yeah,
for sure.
Well,
what's going on in Abu Ghraib or what's going on or above grade?
What's going on in Guantanamo Bay?
I mean,
what,
what is that kind of torture doing more terrorists or something?
Well,
you were talking about the last time we were discussing
chemical waterboarding.
Yeah.
This chemical Laurium malaria disease that they,
what?
This,
there's a drug called Laurium that my friend took.
Got Complete am,
yeah.
So this drug Laurium,
they give it to prisoners in Guantanamo Bay in really high doses when they first
get there.
And you know,
it has the potential for causing amnesia.
And when you have amnesia,
that's when someone can really control you because you don't remember who you
are.
And so someone will just tell you who you are.
This is all detainees at Guantanamo Bay.
All of them.
They're all taking this Larry Defense Department,
forest,
all war on terror,
detainees at the Guantanamo Bay prison to take a high of
a controversial anti-malarial drug.
It's the actual term is male effective quote Queen Melphalan Queens.
Is this a,
does this affect only have only affects a certain percentage of people that take
it?
You?
Well,
only if you're like allergic to it or something.
it gives you shitty dreams minimum.
I mean,
some people maybe don't have that,
but it'll give you shitty dreams.
But that's it.
A regular dose.
They're giving these poor bastards,
huge doses of this stuff.
So I mean,
you're already going crazy.
You've been kidnapped by,
you know,
you've been kidnapped by Weirdos.
A lot of those people were shepherds,
you know,
they were just out there like doing nothing.
They were just farmers and they were in the wrong place at the wrong time.
Swept up without a trial and a black helicopter.
Never see your kids or your family again.
You could take into this weird island by these psychopaths who start poisoning
you.
It's not an America and it's not an America.
How does not America there in Cuba.
That's crazy.
That's in Cuba too.
It's very crazy.
And it's called,
I mean the U S Army Public Health physician is the one who named it
pharmacologically.
Waterboarding.
Wow.
There was a US army physician that they came up with that term pharmacological
waterboarding.
Cause when you have amnesia,
you don't remember who you are and you start believing what people are saying to
you.
They're like,
yes you are a terrorist.
You are involved in,
oh I thought they would tell them something nice.
It's you're a clown.
You live in this.
If you live in this,
in this room now,
this little cement room.
Yeah,
and that's your home.
This is what they should do.
That to them at least be a little,
make them feel a little better.
It's fucking insane to think about being killed.
Like imagine like just to reverse that you're walking down the street,
you're in Culver city,
a helicopter comes down,
grabs you,
carries you away.
Suddenly you're in some weird brick building with people who you can't even
understand what they're saying.
There's a translator with him.
They're just like telling you what,
tell us what you did.
We know what you did,
where the rest of the attacks going to happen.
Well,
they said that the,
the,
the premise that they would deliver it to,
as they say in Casey's people had malaria,
but before they would even test them from malaria,
they would give them a dose five times higher than the prophylactic dose giving
to individuals to prevent the disease.
And that made my friend completely forget his past.
But did he eventually remembers it now?
Well,
yeah,
but it took,
is it a temporary?
That's what's scary about it,
man.
Look up labored.
It says there,
it was invented by US army and was routinely given to soldiers deployed
overseas.
What the hell.
Look up Larry him suicide note.
There's this famous suicide note by a guy,
lost his shit on Larry Him and then just killed himself.
If you really want to like see how bad they should is,
this is a really dark,
dark thing cause well they'll probably given it to soldiers to prevent malaria
and then they realize like,
Whoa,
this uh,
this has a very unique property.
All the best drugs come out of a military stuff,
right?
Like meth from like air,
like um,
air force.
Yeah.
Well not air force.
He was like,
I think it was Japan and Germany and we're the first people to come up with it,
I believe,
or the first people to harness it for military reasons.
Did they invent ecstasy for the war?
MTMA imagine.
It's like everyone's on ecstasy.
They certainly did some experimenting with it.
They also did experiments with DMT the way Terence Mckenna first found out about
DMT.
He knew a guy worked at the army research lab and the guy came over with a
barrel full of this stuff.
Yeah.
He said the army had a barrel of this shit.
They're all of DMT.
They had synthesize a fucking barrel.
This shit,
the purest of the pure clean white damn micro drop would do it an effect.
Well you'd smoke it,
but yeah,
he said that they had just an insane supply,
this stuff and and Mckenna was.
That was how was he was introduced to DMT.
It was the army's fucking DMT that got Terence Mckenna Hi.
The first time.
And then he was like,
Whoa,
Lee Shit.
And then he went from there,
you know,
to become the Terence Mckenna.
We all knew in La.
He got high the first time.
My military grade DMT,
first time he got high on DMT.
It was from the fucking US army research lab supply that some guy who he used to
refer to as the real Terence Mckenna.
He knew a guy like many of us do growing up,
this guy was kind of underground and this is the guy that was the real guy who
told him about all this stuff and sort of hit was his guru of all these things.
Some cat.
There was a scientist and Mckenna Mckenna got ahold of DMT from him for the
first time and you know,
he said that they basically had a hold them down.
Like,
you know,
he just couldn't stop saying,
I can't believe it.
I cannot believe it.
I cannot believe this is real.
I can like what he's saying.
Or you saw the barrel,
what he saw my,
he had his idea of what drugs were.
I mean he had psychedelic experiences.
He had had LSD,
he had done morning glory seeds and that's a pretty intense visionary
experiences.
But the description of DMT,
that's probably the best one that I've ever come up with is mushrooms times a
million plus aliens that if you think that mushrooms are crazy and they are
crazy,
mushrooms are absolutely mind blowing.
Life changing things and you think,
well that's about as crazy as they can get.
And then you do DMT and he'd go,
oh wait,
this isn't even thinkable.
I couldn't even have made this up.
I can almost imagine mushrooms all most,
not really,
but almost.
But then DMT just,
and then inside the DMT trips,
a lot of times you'll have,
it'll show you something that's impossible and it show you something a million
times more impossible.
Like you think you've hit the Andy,
like this is how could this be and that wall,
do you remember these things or do you just remember think seeing you remember
seeing something that's impossible?
Dj Talk Pom wants to
it.
He's thinking it's very appealing.
So I made it happen.
I want to see impossible stuff.
Um,
the best way to remember it is to write it down or to talk about it and record
it.
But the true memory of it,
the true memory,
if I had to be completely honest with you,
it's very fragmented.
It's very,
um,
like there's lessons that I learned for sure.
And there's images that I still recall and there's feelings that I can remember,
like being in the middle of it and having these feelings,
but it slips through your fingers.
It's like a super psychedelic dream where you wake up and you're like,
what the fuck was that?
And then five minutes later you kind of don't remember.
Sorry,
trying to carry the ocean home and your hands.
Yes.
And you feel,
but you,
you,
I see.
But you still feel good from it.
It's like somebody whispered the secret of everything into your ear and it's
good news and then you're like,
oh,
but you can't verbalize it.
Yeah.
And you can't remember.
You can't,
but you just feel after you've done it.
It's a snapchat.
It's a snap.
I snap chat with God and what it is,
God sends you a snapchat
if that is what it is.
It's kind of a snapshot.
Put it man,
in a way.
Um,
and then you have the memory of that pussy in your face.
Wow.
Yeah.
You just remember it's,
it's amazing.
It's life changing in a really positive way.
Like it's for most people.
But I've heard some people have some really horrendous experiences on it too.
Yeah.
Like dark or the girl who did the DMT,
em,
Emma and she said she was just like going through,
she took it.
Oh yeah.
I want to get her on the podcast,
man.
What's your name?
Neuro soup.
Shura,
you're a youtube channel.
She was also the girl that was a part of that whole thing
thing with,
I'm that guy that had a MDM,
a lab ls.
The missile silo was the LSD lab.
Oh,
it was her.
I saw that documentary.
Yeah.
It was a vice piece.
She was the girlfriend?
Yes.
Wasn't that Hamilton Morris?
Wasn't that Hamilton?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It was happening and it was a a vice piece.
She was the girlfriend.
She was a stripper and she met this guy who was a drug dealer and it became,
this,
I mean is a wild story.
I really want to stop there.
I want people to not get it from me,
just get it in its entirety.
I highly recommend it.
It's really cool.
It's creepy.
Really creepy.
Crazy scary.
Like sad that someone could be into these mind expanding drugs and then be so
dark.
Like he just took it to like a dark sort of place.
I mean,
he was a fucking informant for the government.
I mean it was really,
it got really crazy.
A drug dealer became an informant.
I'm not telling you any.
You've got to look it up.
It's a goddamn great movie.
It would be a great movie if somebody like did like just a factual accounts with
no fuckery.
You don't have to doctor it up at all.
It's,
it's an amazing account.
Neuro soup is her name on Youtube.
She's got some great videos on Youtube and uh,
her youtube stuff and then her Hamilton Morris thing.
I don't remember what the,
uh,
what Hamilton Morris,
his title of it was.
You find it,
let people know.
But um,
yeah,
look,
there's some weird stories out there.
People have done some terrible things.
Don't put DMT in your asshole may or do well,
what happened?
What's her report?
She's still,
she's still with us.
Right?
I think what happens when you put in your asshole is probably pretty similar to
what happens when you do it intravenously.
And the intravenous trips that were reported by a doctor,
Rick Strassman in the book,
Dmt,
the spirit molecule,
they were very long.
They were like,
instead of 10 to 15 minutes,
there's the normal DMT trip.
There were more than a half hour.
And I'm much more intense.
It seemed like that people got like right to the source.
Hamilton's Pharmacopia but yeah,
but that's the name of his show.
What's the name of the specific episode?
I'm sure.
Good.
But her report was like,
it wasn't getting to this sore.
She was like,
neurosis crapped in.
These tunnels are,
yeah,
Crystal Crystal's name,
K r y.
S t.
L.
E,
Hamilton Morris and neuro sue.
But we just Google that you'll find it.
But Hamilton is a very cool guy.
Very interesting guy.
Has a lot of really fascinating uh,
videos and articles about,
um,
various psychedelics.
If he's a very bright guy,
knows a lot about them on top of being just kind of a cool Weirdo.
You know,
he was on the podcast.
We fucked up.
We got them too high,
too high.
He came over,
he came over to talk to me about the tank and we went into the basement.
He's,
he can,
he can get too high.
He seems like he's just a drunk in the whole world.
Can get too high.
I got to high red van got too high and we went too deep.
We are.
We got fucked up because it was one of the only other time we did that was,
we definitely did that with Anthony Bourdain too because we like fucking
Anthony.
He seems kind of cool.
He's very cool.
Can I held his shit together?
Yeah,
he's very cool.
I really love that guy.
But we,
we just kept going.
I kept handing the joint.
He kept talking and I was like this,
this mother fucker even know.
Cause the people who live in New York,
I mean I knew he's a guy who's experienced a lot of substances,
right?
So I knew he'd be fine,
but at a certain point in time,
the body just has a breakdown.
Even Joey Diaz,
we had probably seven,
eight hits and you know where that goes.
Yeah.
You're talking on a podcast like good fucking,
you might be able to keep it together if you didn't have to talk,
but just managing your thoughts and talking at the same time.
It's fucking,
it's problematic.
Okay.
Yeah.
Have you heard that thing that you can smoke yourself sober?
You think that's true?
I've heard that,
but I think people just forget what sober.
What do you mean smoke yourself sober?
They apparently like you're not stoned anymore.
We're going to charge.
It starts triggering a thing in your brain that actually acts as an antidote or
something.
Like you get a high enough dose and it starts having a reverse effect.
Sounds like something.
Yeah,
man.
You get to,
you get sober,
man.
I wonder.
Okay,
let's,
let's go with that.
Can you smoke yourself sober?
Small smoke yourself.
It's fucking one of the first things you look up in Google.
It's right there.
Okay,
let's find out.
What is the CIO answers.
Okay.
Smoking yourself sober is possible.
Read here from marijuana.com so you know,
it's got to be legit.
They sponsor Doug Benson's bathroom.
They sponsor everything he does.
Uh,
I figured out that the cannabinoid receptors in your body absorbed well.
What does this word?
Some fucking guy was really smart dude.
Relax.
Okay.
This is hilarious because he obviously cut and pasted the word because there's a
different font between,
I have figured out the cannabinoid receptors in the body absorb
smaller.
Yeah.
It's in a capital letter smaller than all the rest in the font becomes smaller
for the rest of the thing.
So he copied and pasted it in wordpress.
This is one of those articles written by the robot she was talking about?
No,
this Guy Wade just smoked himself sober when he wrote this article.
This guy fucked up is what he did because now I'm not buying your bullshit side
and this is the word and uh,
damn mind and a damn I a m and a and d.
Sorry.
Okay,
well that's not so we get sober halfway through your session.
It's just because you finished breaking down the old THC basically.
Okay.
He doesn't know what the fuck he's talking now.
He doesn't Dunkin,
let's smoke.
I smoked myself sober.
Let's try it.
This guy's response,
I feel like in theory that first half sounded really good.
Then your baked didn't.
This just took you down a different path.
It's hard to reach giant premises when there's a carousel spinning around in
your head playing music if you get what I'm saying.
I feel like although theoretically it is possible,
I doubt one would ever fill up every receptor in their brain with THC thus
halting a further increase of your high.
I think you just get so high you forget your high.
All right.
That's my theory.
It's much easier Ockham's razor go with that.
You forgot what sober is.
You're so baked.
You forgot.
Well,
I'm sober dude.
You forgot what being sober really feels like.
He's just talking shit.
Right.
I don't like to get that high.
I mean either.
I used to though.
I'd like to get that high.
If I know I'm going to do something like flying a plane.
Really that all men hate that.
That's when I would be thinking about this,
the plane and got to force yourself to every little,
every little thing,
every little thing that could go wrong.
Focused on that.
Yeah.
I think it's good though.
It's good to have those experiences every now and then because when you land,
you feel so good about life.
You so happy.
He just sobered up and nothing happened and you're like,
God,
I'm going to be okay.
But a plane is a good place to get really hard because you're in a relatively
safe place outside of the fact,
like when it's,
I've been so hard to keep it together.
I've been so high in a plane.
When I was taking off then I thought I was going to start screaming like for a
quick,
quick second.
Aria Hall said,
once it happens,
man,
you feel like you're going to have a heart attack because it's like,
yeah,
this sounds great.
But then when you're in the air and also the time shit man,
remember on Air France,
remember that?
Which one are we went to England.
Yeah.
What happened?
I just remember having ingested and maybe some more coming onto the end of the
airport area,
way outside the airport.
I remember working near where it's at,
where it's legal.
I remember taking an edible in Colorado after the war,
after the war,
but like Joe,
because it's like,
it's like the UFC.
They've hooked him up with these FirstClass insane seats.
I've,
I still think about it like every couple of days.
I'll think about that flight just because it was so luxurious.
I'd never been in a,
you're like flying with the Illuminati.
There's like Dutch oil billionaires across from you or act like it's normal.
You watch him like take their shoes off and put on new pants.
They have like luxury flying clothes that they wear.
Pajamas,
pajamas,
they put on their pajamas and your seat goes all the way back and it's a big,
huge weird bubble seat they can swirl around.
But so it's a perfect place to be super high until we hit fucking turbulence.
Remember that?
Oh yeah.
And when the captain came on and said,
this turbulence is probably going to keep up for the rest of the flight and I am
fucking high man.
Like scared.
Like you're,
I'm just thinking,
how would you do that?
Well,
I gotta I gotta get drunk at the airport.
That's what I do because I've been in those turbulent flights where it's like
three hours of turbulence.
It's the worst drink and then you're like kind of not as terrified.
Unfortunately.
Gentleman.
We're out of time.
Sorry to end on that story.
Sorry.
Sorry to freak everybody out.
What else happened,
Doug?
It is that the end of the story.
That's how it goes to that.
Your show,
your show on Youtube.
How do people find it again?
Pound House.
You can go to my website,
Doug pound with two gs.com or just go,
thank you so much for the insights.
I'm going to burn some of this.
[inaudible] thank you.
Gave it to me.
I love the smell of this shit.
It's so perfect.
So it,
it's a beautiful way.
Can you like champ?
Well,
we do our podcast sponsors home.
want to thank our sponsors.
Thanks to Tang.
Thanks to go to rogan.ting.com save 25 bucks off your first phone.
Thanks also to onnit.com go to o n N.
I n
t used the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off.
Any else?
Oh uh,
I will be traveling to Miami tomorrow.
Oh,
so excited.
I'll be with young Tony Hinchcliffe
be going to the Fillmore,
playing at the Jackie Gleason.
Oh,
in Miami tomorrow night.
You'll be Kaa motherfuckers and then,
um,
I will be in Baltimore and Orlando
by the end of the month
cited those shows are almost sold out,
but there's still some tickets left for Miami.
Orlando is a April 18th,
Baltimore is the 25th.
Got a Joe and.net for tickets.
If you want to listen to one of the most awesome podcast and the history of the
universe,
then you want to listen to the Duncan Trussell family hour that's
available@duncantrussell.com.
It's also available on iTunes.
It's also
stitcher.
The university
wants you to be a part of this and you want to be a part of the universe since
you already are.
How pretentious.
Imagine if I said the only way to be a part of the university's,
if you pay attention to us,
that's pretty ridiculous,
but I mean it.
So get on it.
Oh,
and it is,
where'd Rogan say 10% off?
All right,
we'll be back next week.
Uh,
we got a lot of great podcasts coming up next week.
Um,
I don't even want to tell you who it is
cause I want to surprise you with awesomeness.
So a much love everybody seen next weekend.
And,
uh,
for everyone,
a big hug and a big kiss.
Bye.